OKAY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
RULES WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING IN
THE- STREET BUILDING IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RISK. THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCES
THE PATIENT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE THE
PARTICIPATING TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS PUT ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN A
COUPLE OF TIMES TODAY IT'S UP
NOW- THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AN ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO. I MIGHT HAVE SAID THAT
WRONG SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO OKAY. I WILL REMAIN-
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. AND ALSO FOR
OUR COURT REPORTER I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK ALL SPEAKERS AND MY
COLLEAGUES ALIKE. AS WELL AS
WITNESSES. TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY- IF FOR SOME REASON WE
DON'T GET YOUR VOICE CLEARLY I
WILL STOP YOU AND LET YOU KNOW
SO THAT WE CAN BE SURE RECORD.
YOUR TESTIMONY. BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND AS A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES YOU'LL
NEED TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
FOR THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME
WE VOTE. SO WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROVE YOUR GROWTH HERE
KAMLAGER HERE KAMLAGER HERE
LAYERED HERE LAYERED HERE BATES
HERE BATES HERE ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE. THANK YOU- IF THERE
ARE NO OBJECTIONS I'D LIKE TO
TAKE UP OUR FIRST ON TODAY'S
AGENDA- ARE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND THAT WOULD BE ITEMS
TO E. F. AND G. THESE ARE
APPOINTMENTS L. AS MEMBERS OF
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION IS IT
OKAY IF WE TAKE THOSE UP
TOGETHER I SEE NO ONE ASKING FOR
A SPLIT VOTE SO. OUR MOTION
WOULD BE GREAT. HI HE'S SENATOR
LATE. CENTER LAYERED HAS MADE A
MOTION FOR ITEMS TO E. F. AND G.
THAT I'M SECRETARY WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GROWTH. GROVE I AM
LONGER HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
LAYERED I BATES AYE BATES AYE
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE FIVE TWO
ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO- WE COULD
ALSO TAKE A MOTION FOR ITEM
THREE BILL REFERRALS AND ITEM
FOR FLOOR A KNOWLEDGE MINTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR KAMLAGER A
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL GROWTH I PROVIDE KAMLAGER I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. BY LAYERED
AYE BATES AYE BATES AYE ATKINS
AYE A CONCISE FIVE TWO ZERO FIVE
TWO ZERO THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES. WE WILL NOW TURN TO
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND WE WILL
START WITH ITEM ONE A. AND THAT
IS THE APOINTMENT OF JOSE M.
HERNANDEZ AS A MEMBER OF THE
REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. REGENT HERNANDEZ LET
ME WELCOME YOU AND OFFER YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO OUR
THANK ANYONE AND GO AHEAD AND DO
OPENING COMMENTS. AND THEN- WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SO WITH THAT LET ME
JUST LOOK UP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF CENTER BROKE DOWN
MACINNES AND THE REST OF THE S.
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
SENATORS A LAYER COM LOGGER
BATES AND NOW THE ROLE. OF FOR
GIVING ME THAT TIME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU AT
THIS HEARING. I AM HUMBLED TO BE
ASKED BY THE GOVERNOR TO SERVE A
FULL TERM AS A REGENT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND IF
CONFIRMED. I AM VERY HONORED TO
DO SO I WOULD LIKE TO JUST TAKE
THE TIME TO THANK MY WIFE OF
THIRTY YEARS AGO AND MY FIVE
KIDS YES FIVE KIDS- JULIO CARINO
BY NEST ON MERIT. AND ANTONIO A
WHO IN THEORY SHOULD BE WATCHING
OUT THIS THESE PROCEEDINGS AND
ALLOW FOR THEIR CONTINUED
SUPPORT IN EVERYTHING THAT I
CHOOSE TO DO. I A. R. I BELIEVE
THAT ON THE APPEAL TO ME OF
REACHING THE AMERICAN DREAM I'M
A OUT FIRST GENERATION MEXICAN
AMERICAN. WHO GREW UP AS A
MIGRANT FARMWORKER USED TO
TRAVEL- STARTING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THEN IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENDING UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA NINE MONTHS OUT OF
THE YEAR. AND THEN HEAD BACK TO
MY PARENTS HOMETOWN IN. MEXICO
WHEN HE IN THIS COUNTRY- BECAUSE
I SIMPLY BECAUSE I WAS. DURING
THE SOME HARVEST MONTHS I HAVE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS THAT WERE
BORN IT MATH. BUT HARD WORK.
PERSEVERANCE AND THE GUIDANCE OF
OUR PARENTS FORMALLY HAVE A
THIRD GRADE EDUCATION I WAS ABLE
TO- TO GO TO SCHOOL AND BE
SUCCESSFUL AS MATTER OF FACT I
WAS SELECTED AS PART OF THE
NINETEENTH CLASS OF U. S. NASA
ASTRONAUTS. BEFORE ATTENDING
GRADUATE SCHOOL- BEFORE THAT I
ATTENDED GRADUATE SCHOOL AT UC
SANTA BARBARA I HAVE A DAUGHTER
WHO GRADUATED. FROM THERE IF
YOU'RE YEARS AGO AND I HAVE A
FRESHMAN SON IN MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING ATTENDING I UC
MERCED. I ALSO WORK ALMOST
SIXTEEN YEARS AT LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE NATIONAL LABORATORY
I'M CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGIES
ODD LIKE DEVELOPING A SPACE
SPACE X. RAY LASER AS A DEFENSE
SHIELD. I ALSO WILD I AM VERY
PROUD TO SAY THAT I WAS ONE OF
TWO- INVESTIGATORS THAT
DEVELOPED THE FIRST FULL FULL
FIELD. DIGITAL MAMMOGRAPHY
SYSTEM FORTY EARLIER DETECTION
OF BREAST CANCER AND NOW FINALLY
I WORKED AT LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
LAB IN SEVERAL NUCLEAR
NONPROLIFERATION RUSSIAN- BASED
PROJECTS. STRONG TICKET
EDUCATION AND HAVE A FOUNDATION
OF NAME FOR STARS FOCUS. ON
EXPOSING OUR KIDS TO THE WORLD
OF STEM I HAVE ALSO SERVED A
FULL NINE YEAR TERM AS A REGION
OF MY UNDERGRADUATE ALMA MATER
UNIVERSITY OF THE PACIFIC AND
SHOWS TO BURKE PURSUE THE
OPPORTUNITY OF SERVING AT A
HIGHER LEVEL. HERE AS THE UC
YEAH BECAUSE I STRONGLY BELIEVE
I CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
GENERAL MY GOALS AS A UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA REGION. TO ASSIST
IN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF POLICY
IN THE AREAS OF PERSONNEL AND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE TEN CAP.
FOR WHAT THERE'S- NATIONAL
LABORATORIES I WILL WORK TO THE
STUDENTS THAT WILL HELP.
INSECURITIES HOUSING FOOD AND
CHILDCARE ADMISSION AND
FINANCIAL AID EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT I LOOK TO SERVE IN THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT OF THE UNIVERSITY.
THE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE TO ENSURE
THEY ARE WORKING TOWARDS THE
BEST INTERESTS OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WHICH OUR STUDENTS
STAFF FACULTY MEMBERS AND
TAXPAYERS AND IF NEEDED PROVIDE
ADVICE ON KEY PERSONNEL
ASSIGNMENTS. I WILL LEAVE MY
OPENING STATEMENT BRIEF SO I MAY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR
THAT STATEMENT AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON ALL OF THE
SUCCESSES IT'S QUITE A IT'S
QUITE A RESUME- AND IT'S GOOD TO
HAVE YOU WITH US TODAY I THINK I
WILL ASK MY VICE CHAIR IF SHE
WOULD LIKE TO START US OFF- WITH
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU I'M MADAM PRO TEN AND- LET
ME I SHARE MY- COMMENTS ABOUT
YOUR RESUME AND HOW YOU ACHIEVE
THE AMERICAN DREAM SOULFUL
VARIANCE INSPIRATIONAL. AND
CERTAINLY THAT'S BEEN PASSED ON
THROUGH YOUR FAMILY AND I'M SURE
MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE SEEN YOUR
RESUME AND SENIOR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. ARE EQUALLY
AMAZED OUT SOMEONE WHO. IT'S NOT
AND EVEN TO OUR COUNTRY YEAH HAS
AND SHE SO MUCH AND IT HAS BEEN
SUCH AN INSPIRATION TO THOSE WHO
WILL FOLLOW AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE ALL HOPE TO DO BUT
YOU'RE A KIND OF AT THE TOP OF
THE- THE TOP OF THE LIST OF
ACHIEVING THAT FLOW- IT'S MY
HONOR ACTUALLY TO SIT ON RULES
AND HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO. ASK
QUESTIONS REGARDING OUR YOUR-
AND ONE IN PARTICULAR THAT I
THINK WAS DISTURBING TO ME IN
MANY MANY OFF PROBABLY WHO CAME
THROUGH THE EDUCATION SYSTEM A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO WAS A
REVISION OF THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE MATH CURRICULUM. AND I
THINK THERE WERE PROBABLY
ALLEGATIONS ACCUSATIONS THAT WE
WERE DUMBING DOWN OUR MATH
CURRICULUM AND- OBVIOUS. WHAT
PLEASE A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
YOUR BILL TO ACHIEVE IN THE IN
THE WORLD UPSIDE SO AND
CERTAINLY. SO COULD YOU COMMENT
ON ON WHERE WE GO FROM HERE I
BELIEVE THERE HAS BEEN OFF. FOR
DIVE INTO THAT WHOLE ISSUE AND
HOPEFULLY WE'RE COMING. CORRECT
ON TO. LOOKING AT REQUIRED A
MORE MATH MORE SO. OF OUT OR-
PUBLIC LEVEL FROM CERTAINLY. THE
ON. THE ON NINE THROUGH TWELVE
GRADES SO THAT THEY ARE
COMPETITIVE CERTAINLY WILL-
COLLEGE ENTRANCE AND CERTAINLY
ALL THOSE COMING FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT SEEM TO REALLY BE
FOCUSING ON THAT. KIND OF A
LITTLE INTRODUCTION TO OF A
QUESTION THAT- IF YOU COULD
SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT THAT
WOULD BE. VERY HELPFUL TO ME IF
I SPEAK TO MY CONSTITUENTS WHO
ARE PARENTS IN PARTICULAR WHO
ALL CHILDREN ARE I THINK AT THE
CUSP OF ENTERING ON. THE ARM
NINE THROUGH TWELVE YEARS IN
HIGH SCHOOL. WHAT THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CENTER BATES FOR- FOR
THAT QUESTION VERY INTERESTING
QUESTION AND- I AM. A STRONG
ADVOCATE OF THEM EDUCATION I'M A
STRONG ADVOCATE- THAT WE NEED TO
INCREASE THE DIAMETER OF THE
PIPELINE KATE TO TWELVE- IN
TERMS OF ENGAGING THESE KIDS. AT
A YOUNG AGE TO BE INTERESTED IN
SCIENCE AND MATH AND NOT TO SHY
AWAY FROM ME ESPECIALLY
NONTRADITIONAL- A POPULATIONS
LIKE GIRLS AND MAPS. YOU KNOW
THE GIRLS CAN BE SHY AWAY FROM
THAT AND WE NEED TO BREAK THAT
STIGMA DOESN'T AND- GET THEM
INVOLVED. EARLY ON NOW. WHEN I
WANT TO BE A ASTRO HOW DOES
YEARS OLD AND MERE GRADE. WHEN I
SAW THE VERY LAST THE PROBLEM-
THAT LANDED ON THE MOON AND
WATCHING ASTRONAUT GENE CERNAN
WALKS ON THE SURFACE OF THE MOON
AND I KNEW DARREN BAND WATCHING
AND LISTENING TO ASTRONAUT GENE
CERNAN POPULATION CONTROL
HOUSTON THAT I WANTED. TO DO
THAT. KILEY WHAT MOTOR TO GET
INTO MATH AND SCIENCE IN WE NEED
TO THINK. OUR KIDS AT A YOUNGER
AGE- JUST LIKE THAT I TV. UNUSED
GAUGED. N. N. M. DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO IN THE TO BE ABLE TO
GET THEM INTERESTED WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE HIGH SCHOOLS
REQUIRE. THREE YEARS OF SCIENCE
THAT THEY REQUIRE IT- MASSIVE
THAT THEY CAN COME IN AND BE
WELL PREPARED AND- YOU SEE
SYSTEMS TO BE SUCCESSFUL. YOU
KNOW- SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY IS
THE HEART BEAT HARD ECONOMY AND
NOT ONE I. DO READ THE
STATISTICS SAYING THAT THE US
ONLY GRADUATES THE THOUSAND
ENGINEERS A YEAR AND YOU LOOK AT
WHAT. INDIA IN SRI. VETERANS SIX
AND THOUSAND I RESPECT THE A YOU
I YOU KNOW YOU MAY WANT SAY WELL
THAT'S A LOT. IT IS A LOT BUT WE
FIVE YEARS FROM AND YOU KNOW
GOING BE THE THAT ARE THE FOR OF
TAKING IF WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT NOW AND SO I'M ALL FOR
HOW DO WE DO THAT HELP REACH WE
GOT WE HAVE TO ENGAGE THE KIDS
AT A YOUNG AGE HE BERMAN GAUGE
AND ESTABLISH A RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEM. TEMPUS SO THAT ONE
DAY- THE ARE GOING TO COLLEGE
AND HOPEFULLY TO USE SYSTEM. AND
SO IT'S HOW WE OUT WE OUT WE
KEEPING THEM ENGAGED AND ON
ACTIVITIES. THE IN IN IN. THE
MAKE A LONG- EVEN BIT LONG I.
AGREE WITH YOU WE JUST WORKING
FAR HARDER THAN WE DO NOW TO
ENGAGE OUR KIDS AND YOUNGER.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT I THINK
ALL. WILL COME ABOUT THOSE WHO
FALL BEHIND IN THAT. IF WE
REQUIRE SOMETHING HIGHER THAN
THAT MAKES THEM EVEN MORE.
OUTSIDE THE REALM OF OPPORTUNITY
AND I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT I
THINK THE SCHOOL HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY. FROM ON THE ONE
IF YOU TAKE THE BELL SHAPED
CURVE WELL WE FROM THEM. ONE
INTO THE OTHER TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY. AND
THOSE WHO HAVE PROBABLY HAD A
DIFFERENT. UPBRINGING ON MAYBE
NOT AS MUCH EXPOSURE WHICH I
HOPE CERTAINLY THERE ARE.
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR BRAND AND OUR
ABILITIES AND THEY ARE GIVEN
THAT YOUR- IN THE EARLIER YEARS
THAT TO SWITCH. OFF FOR STUDENTS
WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH LET'S. OF
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH EIGHTH
GRADE AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
NOT BEING. ABLE TO TAKE ALGEBRA
ONE SO THAT THEY CAN MOVE
THROUGH. THE HIGHER OF COURSE
DECIDE IS WHAT REALLY TROUBLED
MY CONSTITUENT ON PARENTS. SO ON
. YOUR ANSWER ON ABOUT IT SO YOU
NEED TO KEEP RAISING THE FLAG ON
THAT ONE FOR SURE. BECAUSE I
THINK WE TRY TO COMPENSATE. IN A
DIFFERENT FASHION FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE NOT HAD. THE EXPOSURE AND
THE OPPORTUNITY THERE'S ANOTHER
WAY TO COMPENSATE FOR THAT
RATHER THAN TRYING TO. YOU KNOW
USE THE TERM THAT MY PARENTS AND
WAS IN THE PRESIDENT BEING DOWN. CREASE THE OP. BILLABLE JOBS
NOT OKAY WE'RE GOING YOU KNOW
MAKE YOU MEAN AND THEN OUT NOTE
SAYS YOU'RE NOT AS GOOD AS
OTHERS WHO CAME TO YOU AND THAT
SORT DOESN'T ALSO FEEL WHICH
HUGE HUGE SELF HUGE IN PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO ACHIEVING AN
EDUCATION ONE LAST QUESTION UP
ON IS ABOUT THE THAT RATHER
INCREDIBLY LARGE SALARIES FOR
PROVIDING OUR COUNSELORS WHEN I
SPEAK TO THE PEOPLE WHO RAN OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION- OINTMENTS ARE
THERE ARE. TALKING ABOUT. AND
COST FROM AFFORDABILITY SO THAT
EDUCATION IS THERE FOR EVERYONE.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT THE SALARIES
THAT WERE RECENTLY INCREASED AND
NOW THE DISCUSSION ABOUT. HOW
MUCH TUITION IS THERE SHOULD BE
AN THE 5% CAP MAYBE BUT THE
REGION'S HAVE AN ABILITY TO
INCREASE THAT. WHEN YOU INCREASE
SALARIES THIS MUCH FOR EXAMPLE
UCLA GETTING- FORTY A HUNDRED.
THOUSAND DOLLARS SENSE THE THIRD
BASE NOW. YOU KNOW SIX ALMOST
SIX FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ARE
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE SHOCKING
NUMBERS WHEN WE THINK ABOUT KIDS
HAVING FOOD IN SECURITY MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AW NO HOUSING AND
WE'RE PAYING A ONE INDIVIDUAL
THAT.BOB I. THE RATION IS A
NIGHT HIGHER HOW WE TRIED TO YOU
KNOW MEET THIS- PERCENTILE
THOUGHT ON WHEN I WAS THE CITY
IN ALSO A SUPER THAT WAS JUST GO
A LOT WE HAVE TO KEEP TALENT BY
KEEPING WITHIN THAT MEAN
ARRANGEMENT SOME OF THOSE I DO
BELIEVE ARE EXAGGERATED SO LET
ME HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO FORWARD AND
MEET THESE LIVING COSTS WHICH
ALSO INCLUDE PENSIONS THAT GOAL
THE LIFETIME OF ALL THESE FOLKS
AND WE COULD BE LOOKING AT A
RECESSION. IN THE NEAR FUTURE
AND THAT WON'T AFFECT THOSE
SALARIES I WOULD ASSUME THE BILL
CERTAINLY AFFECT THE ABILITY OF
OUR HIGHER ED INSTITUTIONS TO
PROVIDE THE KIND OF- CLASSES AND
CERTAINLY. THE AFFORDABILITY
ISSUE FOR THOSE WHO WILL BE
CERTAINLY AFFECTED OUR WHEN WE
HAVE A RECESSION AND THE ABILITY
TO PAY. FOR CLASSES AND COLLEGE
EDUCATION. R. I APPRECIATE THE-
FIFTY QUESTION A SENATOR BATES
AND- AND YOU KNOW THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT THEUC SYSTEM IS A
PRE MERE EDUCATION SYSTEM IT'S A
MODEL TO BE FOLLOWED IF THE
MODEL THAT EVERYBODY ADMIRES AND
LOOKS UP TO- BUT- THE WAY WE GOT
HERE IS WE WANT TO HIRE THE
BEST. AND RETAIN THE BEST SO
THAT THEY CAN REMAIN OUR
PROGRAMS CAN REMAIN VIABLE AT
THE FOREFRONT AND I AM AND BE
COMPETITIVE NOW. I'M I'M I'M
LIKE YOU IN THIS THAT WOULD THAT
LOOK AT COST COST BUT BUT I YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO THROW THE
BABY OUT WITH THE BATHWATER IN
THE SENSE THAT- YOU WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT YOU RETAINING. THE
BEST TALENT- AND ESPECIALLY AT
THOSE CRITICAL POSITIONS- WORD
IT YOU KNOW POLICY GETS
IMPLEMENTED AND IT HAS RIPPLE
EFFECT THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES AND SOUL WHEN I FIRST
SAW THIS I RAISE MY EYEBROWS.
BUT I'M A SCIENCE. I LOOK AT. IN
AND THEN THE DAY IS WHAT SPEED
TO ME- SENT BATES. BECAUSE IT
SAYS YOU KNOW NOT OUT OF. SAN OF
THE CHANCELLOR'S HAD BASS SALARY
THAT WERE SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW.
THE ARE THE- HOW. AS A MATTER OF
FACT GOD AT THE DATE THAT I
BELIEVE IT WAS- SIX SOME. EIGHT
AMONG BELOW THE TWENTY. PERCENT
DOWN. EVEN AFTER THE RAISES THAT
THAT WE VOTED TO GIVE THEM I'LL
TELL YOU. THERE ARE STILL THREE
THAT ARE BELOW THE THIRTIETH
PERCENTILE AT THERE'S- AT THE-
PERCENTILE IN THE REST ARE IN
THE THIRTIETH PERCENTILE SO
WE'RE BIG WILL WELL BELOW THE
FIFTIETH PERCENTILE AND SO THERE
WAS TALK ABOUT WHETHER. YOU KNOW
WE SHOULD GIVE. SENATE YOUR. DO
IN A E. L. I. A. CORRECTION- I
HAVE. WE FELT IT WAS BEST JUST
DO IT AT ONCE IT OVER WITH AND
THEN KEEPING ON. FOR SOME OR
ANOTHER IN PREVIOUS- THE
CHANCELLOR SIR WERE NOT A- AND
THIS IS WHY THEY ALL FELT. THE
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT- OF
PERCENTILE SAW CIVIL WELL DOES
SEEM LIKE A LOT YOU LOOK AT THE-
AT THE SCHOOLS- THAT ARE IN THE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICAN
UNIVERSITIES AND YOU'RE GONNA
SEE THAT THERE ARE. BELOW THE
FIFTIETH PERCENTILE ALL OF OUR
CHANCES ARE IN SEOUL I THINK IT
WAS- IT WAS NEEDED IT WAS
NECESSARY IT'S A SIMPLE YET IT
IS PAINFUL THAT ARE LARGE SALARY
YES IT IS THE LARGE SIDE BUT YOU
GET COMMENSURATE WITH THEIR-
SPONSORS. PLEASE AND. DAHLE THAT
THE MAN. I AM THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THEY MANAGE I IT'S A- WE
COMPARE WILL TO A COUPLE OF RUNS
A COMPANY SO. I THE SALARIES ARE
IN LINE I AND AN I BELIEVE FOR
IT BECAUSE I THERE DEFENSIBLE
THE DATE SIXTEEN. AND HE AFTER
DOUBLES IT'S STILL SPEAKS ME
THAT DID RIGHT. WHAT YOU FOR
THAT REASON AND I KNOW THAT ALL
OF THE- COVERED. WHEN YOU'RE
CITY ON ANY FOR VERY GOOD. TO DO
IS THIS IS LEGIT WILL KEEP THE
TALKED. WORKING FOR WHATEVER ON
PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION THAT WE
ARE ON A DECISION MAKER FOR I
KNOW ON THE BORDERS TO PROVIDE.
IN THE RECESSION WE ARE. TO PAY
CUT BECAUSE IF WE DIDN'T WE
WOULD HAVE LOST PEOPLE AND VERY
CRITICAL DEPARTMENT SO I WOULD
HOLD. THE CHANCELLOR'S AT SOME
POINT IN TIME IF WE EVER GET TO
THAT HOPE WE DONT WOULD
CONSIDER. A MAYBE TAKING- YOU
KNOW MONEY WHERE THEY DIDN'T GET
THEIR CHECK ON THAT MONEY WENT
TO. HELP SOMEBODY A STUDENT OR
SO I DO ON MY FINAL COMMENT ON
IT IS I THINK IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING AFTER. THESE GET.
TOUGH SORRY WHAT ARE MAY AND I
THINK THERE'S A PRETTY CLOSE
COMPARED TO. AND ACCOUNTED.
WITHIN OUR HOUSE. BUT WITH.
THANK YOU- FOR DOING A GREAT.
THE DATA SHOW THAT. WITH THESE
SALARY INCREASES WE WILL NOT
HAVE A- ATTRACTING THE BEST IN
THE- AND I THINK. ONE OF THE
MEASURE THAT NEEDS BE AND- WHEN
WE REVIEW SALARY. ARE WE HAVING
A PROBLEM ATTRACTING THOSE
PEOPLE DON'T THEY WANT TO COME
TO CALIFORNIA. I WORK AT
INCREDIBLE UNIVERSITY LIKE UCLA
OR UC. AND SOME OF OUR BODY BE
OUR COMPARATIVE DATA. THAT'S
INVOVED WITH THE DECISIONS THAT
GO TO. ARE THESE THESE SOME
PRICE SALARIES BUT WITH THAT.
YOU WILL HAVE MY VERY STRONG.
SUPPORT FOR YOUR OUR
CONFIRMATION AND AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALL THAT YOU HAVE
DONE. PROFESSIONALLY AND NOW I'M
CERTAINLY IN THE PUBLIC ARENA
APPRECIATED VERY MUCH. THE BASIC
. THANK YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR-
CENTER COME LONGER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM AND- THANK YOU
MISTER HERNANDEZ FOR YOUR
SERVICE I JUST HAVE. A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR YOU I THINK THAT-
FOIL THE UC REGENTS. I HAVE A
LOT OF WORK IN FRONT OF THEM
BECAUSE YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ONE OF THE BIGGEST AND THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASSETS THAT THE STATE
HAS- YOU KNOW OVER THE WEEKEND I
WAS AT AN EVENT AND INTRODUCED
MYSELF TO THIS YOUNG WOMAN NAMED
DELFINO. I WHOSE EIGHTEEN AND
GETTING READY TO GO TO COLLEGE
AND I SAID WHERE ARE YOU GOING
TO CALL. AND SHE SAID BERKELEY.
AND I WAS OH MY GOODNESS WELL
THANK GOODNESS YOU GOT IN AFTER
ALL THE DRAMA THAT WE WERE
HEARING ABOUT WITH THE HOUSING-
AND SHE GIGGLED BUT IT DIDN'T.
STAY IN MY MIND AND SO I WANTED
TO ASK YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT I WANTED TO KNOW FIRST. I'M
IF YOU'RE SATISFIED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY'S EFFORTS- I GUESS
BERKELEY IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE
OF WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON BUT YOU
CAN CERTAINLY- EXPAND THE ENTIRE
UC SYSTEM. BUT IF YOU'RE
SATISFIED WITH THE UNIVERSITY'S
EFFORTS AROUND DEALING WITH FOOD
INSECURITY- AND ALSO WITH
STUDENT HOUSING. AND THEN THE
SECOND PART OF THAT QUESTION IF
YOU WILL- RELATES TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH BERKELEY AND
MILLS COLLEGE BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN- MILLS
COLLEGE DECLARED A FINANCIAL
EMERGENCY AND IT LAID OFF IN A
NUMBER OF TENURED PROFESSORS-
BECAUSE OF MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
SHORTFALLS. AND ALSO ENROLLMENT
DECLINES. IN SO I'D ALSO LIKE TO
KNOW IF YOU CAN PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON WHERE DISCUSSIONS ARE
BETWEEN MILLS COLLEGE AND
BERKELEY- BECAUSE WE KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LONG STANDING
PARTNERSHIP SO I'S A TWO PARTER
I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA I'D USE
BERKELEY AS THE GLUE. ONE IS AN
UPDATE ON DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN
MALES COLLAGEN BERKELEY AND THAT
IS- YOUR SON HOW THE SCHOOL IS
DOING A TO ADDRESS FOOD
INSECURITY AND HOUSING SHORTAGES
FOR THEIR STUDENTS. YES I WILL
WHAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTION AND- YOU KNOW. D.
AT THE SCHOOLS ARE ADDRESSING
HOUSING INSECURITY WITH RESPECT
TO INCREASING THE NUMBER OF- OF
HOUSING AVAILABLE DEBTS RAND BY
THE UNIVERSITIES I JUST
YESTERDAY I WAS AT UC SAN DIEGO
I WITH CHANCELLOR KHOSLA AND NOW
WE- VIEW- SEVERAL SEVERAL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. THEY'RE
PUT UP. ONE HUNDRED I RESIDENTS
- VETERANS SOUL SOUL. AT THE
UNIVERSITY ARE ARE ARE TRYING TO
DO THEIR PART IN IN IN L. LEVI
ATING THE- THE HOUSING AND
SECURITY ISSUES NOW DIFFERENT
UNIVERSITIES OF THE TEN
CAMPUSES. ARE UP ARE ABLE TO
GROW IN DIFFERENT RATES SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THE FACT WHERE THEY
ARE LOCATED AT THE REALISTIC
THAT THEY HAVE AVAILABLE SO
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM-
QUICKER THAN OTHERS BUT BUT I
THINK EVENTUALLY WERE WE'RE
GOING TO GET THEIR WORKERS
SPECTRUM OOD INSECURITY. I
MONTHS AGO I WAS AT UC- SANTA
BARBARA VISITING UC SANTA
BARBARA AND- AND I KNOW THAT
FOOD IN SECURITY IS- IS A REAL
ISSUE I KNOW THE GOVERNOR HAS-
HAS HERE MARKED SOME MONIES SO
THAT THEY GO TO THE SCHOOL SO
THAT THEY CAN BE USED FOR FOOD
AND. EVEN WHEN I TO UC SANTA I
WENT INTO A CENTER CALLED AS-
WERE A LOT OF THE STUDENTS
CONGREGATE IN ME I UNIVERSITY
HAS A PANTRY PROGRAM BUT YOU FOR
THESE- MIKE ORGAN I AROUND THE
CAMPUSES WERE LIKE AS SOON AND
YOU KNOW RUN THEIR OWN WILL BLOW
PATCH OUT PROGRAM WHERE THIS TO
CAN THEY CAN SEE THEY CAN GROUPS
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO A PRINTER
COMPUTER BUT THEY ALSO HAVE
ACCESS TO FOOD AND SOLD IT'S
THOSE TYPE OF THINGS THESE TYPE
OF INITIATIVE. I HAD TO RE OF
BETTER. TO ADDRESS THE ARE THESE
NEW AND ARE ME IT'S ONLY GET
BEFORE IT GETS SO THE YOU KNOW
ARE TAKING A- ACT OF. WE'RE TO
THE ISSUE OF A MILK YOU KNOW I
JUST CAME ON IN AUGUST AND WE
HAVE NOT DEALT WITH THAT ISSUE-
DURING THE REGENTS MEETINGS BUT
I'LL BE HAPPY TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT ISSUE A WIN AT THE
MILITARIZED MYSELF WELL WITH
THEM BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE- YOU
KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
OPPORTUNITIES THERE BUT BUT BUT-
IF THEY'RE HAVING SO MUCH
TROUBLE YOU KNOW MAYBE THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY THERE FOR FUTURE
EXPAND SO WE CAN KEEP AN EYE ON.
THE I MADE. MAY WANT TO DO IN
THE FUTURE BUT RIGHT NOW I'M- I
CAN'T CALM ON IT BECAUSE I AM
NOT WITH THE SUBJECT IT IS NOT
BEEN UP TO THE REGION'S ON AN
AGENDA AN AGENDA ITEM. OKAY BUT
YOU KNOW I'D APPRECIATE THAT-
REST. MILLS IS A AT THE BELIEVE
IT SING SAY. GENDER AND BERKELEY
NOT SO WHEN YOU ASK JUST ADD
THAT IN THERE ADD THAT LITTLE
COMPLICATED MIX TO IT- BUT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT DOES NEED TO
BE WORKED OUT- IN A WAY THAT IS-
BOTH ETHICAL AND- MAKES SENSE
FOR THE- COMMUNITY OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE THERE TO LEARN AND THE
FOLKS THAT FACULTY WHO ARE THERE
TO TEACH. MY QUESTION ACKERMAN.
REALLY HAS TO DO ACTUALLY WITH-
A RECENT DECISION THAT CAME DOWN
FROM. THE REGIONS AS IT RELATES
TO- UC MEDICAL CENTERS AND
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS. WE KNOW
THAT- YOU SEE SEVEN
COLLABORATING WITH CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS ON PATIENT CARE FOR
SOME TIME AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THAT HAS PROVEN TO BE RATHER
COMPLICATED- BECAUSE OF
CONFLICTING VALUES I KNOW THAT A
VOTE WAS TAKEN I GUESS IT WAS
LAST YEAR IN JUNE. TO APPROVE
NEWSSTAND GOVERNING THE UC
AFFILIATIONS WITH THOSE
HOSPITALS- AND OTHERS THAT
IMPOSE. WRIST ON CARE AND SO
JUST WANTED TO KNOW AND THIS HAS
TO DO WITH RELIGIOUS
RESTRICTIONS- AS IT RELATES TO
MEDICAL DECISIONS. SO HAS THE UC
DEVELOPED IN THE APPROPRIATE
REGULATIONS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
POLICY IS SOLIDIFIED. HEY IT TO
BE HONEST THE- THE ISSUE HAS NOT
COME TO LIGHT IN TERMS OF IT
BEING AN ISSUE I THINK- THE WAY
WE'VE BEEN OPERATING HAS BEEN
FINE AND IT HASN'T COME TO OUR
ATTENTION THAT THERE IS A
CONTROVERSY OR THAT WHATEVER
POLICY IS BEING IMPLEMENTED IS-
IS NOT THE RIGHT POLICY- AND NOT
. WE KNOW WILL BE- WEIGHT IS
COMING DOWN THE LINE HERE AND
YOU KNOW HOW THAT'S GONNA.
AFFECT THE- BUT- WITH RESPECT TO
OUR IT BEING ISSUE I SEE BEING
AN ISSUE RIGHT NOW UNLESS YOU'VE
HEARD OF SOMETHING THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
CENTERS ARE DOING AT THAT IS
CONTRADICTORY TO WHAT THE
CURRENT POLICY IS- I THINK
THINGS ARE WORKING THE WAY THEY
SHOULD BE WORKING AND NOW BACK
TO THE RELATIONSHIP OF THE
CATHOLIC. CALPERS ODD THAT DONE
LIKE YOU SAID I WAS AN ISSUE
THAT WAS THAT WHAT THEY JULY OR
JUNE AND I CAME ON IN THE FALL
SO AGAIN I'M UNFAMILIAR WITH
THAT BECAUSE THERE WAS NO FOLLOW
UP ON SUBSEQUENT. REGENT
MEETINGS. RIGHT THEY HAVE WAS IN
JUNE AS A- OF SOME ISSUES- THAT.
WERE- OBLA MATIC AND THE
LEGISLATURE WAS ACTUALLY IN THE
PROCESS OF TAKING ACTION- RIGHT
BEFORE- THE REGION'S TOOK THIS A
VOTE AND SO IT WAS AS A IT WAS
BECAUSE- THAT YOU SEE DOCTORS
AND LOCAL STUDENTS THAT WERE
PROVIDING CARE. INSIDE CATHOLIC
HOSPITALS HAD TO ABIDE BY THE
RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON THEM BUT
THE CAPITALS AND IN MANY
INSTANCES THAT MEANT-
PROHIBITING ABORTIONS OR
STERILIZATIONS OR CONTRACEPTION-
SOME END OF LIFE OPTIONS AND
ALSO GENDER AFFIRMATION SURGERY
SO THE VOTE THAT WAS CARRIED OUT
IN JUNE. WAS TO- SAY NO TO THAT
BUT SUBSEQUENTLY POLICIES DO
HAVE TO BE IN PLACE TO SOLIDIFY
THAT VOTE THAT WAS TAKEN AND I
THINK IT HAS SOME RELEVANCY NOW.
IN LIGHT OF WHAT'S JUST HAPPENED
AT THE SUPREME COURT SO I'M JUST
GOING TO ASK THAT YOU ALSO PUT A
PIN IN THAT QUESTION AS WELL-
AND ADDS TO BEGIN TO HAVE. YOUR
MEETING THE NEXT TIME YOU EAT
I'M YOU KNOW IT WOULD BE GREAT
FOR YOU TO COME WITH THEM UP
UPDATED INFORMATION ON WHERE THE
UC REGENTS ARE WITH SOLIDIFYING-
OR CODIFYING THAT PARTICULAR
VOTE. BECAUSE IT'S ONE THING TO
VOTE ON IT AND THEN IT'S ANOTHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR. THANK PAN
AM PROTECTING THOSE ARE MY ONLY
. SENATOR THANK VERY MUCH US
SENATOR. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
AND REGION HERNANDEZ- MISTER
HERNANDEZ I AM JUST SO IMPRESSED
BY YOUR BACKGROUND AND YOUR
RESUME YOUR STORY OF WHO YOU ARE
AND HOW YOUR FAMILY AND CAME CAN
BE AND HOW YOU WERE SUCCESSFUL
IN AND AEROSPACE AERONAUTICAL
ENGINEERING AND- THE ASTRONAUT
HERE TO READ THAT YOU IT JUST IS
REALLY VERY AN INSPIRING STORY
AND- I AM GLAD TO SEE. THAT THE
GOVERNOR APPOINTS THE LIKE YOU.
I AM EXCITED BY IT IS BECAUSE
THE NUMBERS THAT YOU QUOTED
EARLIER BELIEVE HE SAID THAT WE
GRADUATE ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND.
AND ENGINEERS ARE UNDERGRADUATE%
ENGINEERS M. A. YEAR AND
COMPARED TO CHINA AT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR INDIA THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. SO WITH YOUR
INSPIRATIONAL STORY I MEAN.
OTHER THAN DOING A SELF
PROMOTIONAL VIDEO AS YOU KNOW
HOW YOU WERE SUCCESSFUL IN THE
STEM AND SITE ANALOGY PROGRAMS.
WHAT'S WHAT'S ON MAKING BURKE
AND I KNOW IT ECHOES THAT THE
QUESTION THAT I MIGHT THE VICE
GRASS. AND ON MAKING. SURE THAT
STUDENT HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
KNOWN. STILL FROM THE- VITAL IN
THERE I MEAN YOU DEVELOP YOU
SAID SOMETHING- EARLIER ABOUT MY
- OR SOME TYPE OR THAT
ELIMINATES BREAST CANCER OR THAT
DOES- YOU KNOW DID EFFECTIVELY
CHANGES THE COURSE OF BREAST
CANCER AND TO BE ON THE CUTTING
EDGE OF THAT TECHNOLOGY HOW
EXCITING. AND SO- WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHTS ON GETTING MORE
STUDENTS INVOLVED IN THAT
EXCITEMENT. AND FIRSTHAND
TECHNOLOGY- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER ROSE- ONE WORD AND THAT
IS OUT OF REACH- WE NEED TO HAVE
THE RESOURCES THE UNIVERSITIES
NEED TO HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO
OUTRAGE WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES
DURING GAMES THE K. TWELVE
PIPELINE THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL
YEAR BUT THEN ALSO TO DEVELOP.
THEM WERE PROGRAMS THAT BRINGS
THE STUDENTS TO THE CAMPUS ALSO
THAT THE STUDENTS CAN SCAN
THEMSELVES IN THE CAMPUS THEY
CAN ENVISION THEMSELVES- IN THE
CAMPUS YOU KNOW I HAVE A I HAVE
A PROGRAM THAT I MODELED AFTER
PROGRAM EX'S FAULT EXPRESS BUT
WE MODEL THAT WE REAP REPLICATED
HERE AT UNIVERSITY OF THE
PACIFIC- I FOUNDATION DID
REACHING FOR THE START OF THE
SUMMER. WHAT WE BRING SEVENTH
THROUGH FIFTH GRADERS ASSETS
SEVENTY TWELFTH GRADERS. ON THE
- TAMPA'S N. N. N. X. THEM FIVE
WEEK. OF LOS STEM PROGRAM HEY ON
PROGRAM WITH PROJECTS AND THEN
WE- STAY IN WITH THEM. THE YEAR
. AND THEN JUST JUST LIKE THE
EXPRESS PROGRAM OUR STUDENTS
THAT STARTED IN THE SEVENTH
GRADE AND HE KEPT PARTICIPATING
TO THE 12100% OF THEM HAVE GONE
ON TO COLLEGE. AND SO IT'S THESE
TYPE OF RESOURCES THAT NEED TO
BE OUR OWN IN THE ACT AT THESE
PROGRAMS SO THEY CAN EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT THEM SO IT'S ENGAGING
WITH THE KIDS AT A YOUNG AGE-
BUT- FORTUNATE THINGS RESOURCES-
BUT I THINK IF THE- CAP. IS WORK
SMARTWAY WHICH NOT CREATE THE
STEP- AND WITH A FOCUS IN STEM
SO SOULS SO AND I'M ALL FOR LEAD
THE CHARGE THEY WANT HELP UP
THEY WANT TO MODEL IT AFTER
WHAT. OUR LESSONS LEARNED YEAH
DON'T. HELLO THE L. SOMETHING
LIKE THAT OKAY ALL THE CAMP. OF
OUR I UNIVERSITY CAL SYSTEM.
THANK YOU SIR VERY MUCH FOR THE
I FORWARD TO SOME YOUR CO. THANK
VERY MUCH IT'S THANK YOU SENATOR
GROW OUR LET ME A SENATOR LOW-
AS THE- ALSO THE RULE COMMITTEE
MEMBER BUT THE CHAIR OF BUDGETS
ONE TO CLOSE US OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND- MMHM
I. NORMALLY WHEN I CHAIR SUB ONE
BECAUSE WE HAD SO MANY HEARINGS
IN JANUARY AND MARCH I WAS MAKE
LIGHT OF THE BACKGROUND OF THE
PEOPLE BEHIND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THE WITNESSES AND I THINK I KNOW
BETTER THAN TO DO THIS ONE
BECAUSE THERE'S A ROCKET AN
ASTRONAUT SUIT WHAT APPEARS TO
BE A PICTURE OF AN ASTRONAUT
CLASS OF HEALTH AND SO. I WOULD
JUST NOTE FROM THE OUR MEETING I
HAD WITH YOU AND ACTUALLY THE
MEETING AFTERWARDS WITH THE TO
CSU TRUSTEES WERE AMONG THE BEST
ONE I'VE HAD WITH POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES ARE WELL ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND I THINK THAT. ARE
YOUR STORY IS POWERFUL YOU'RE-
TRULY QUALIFIES YOU. AND MOST OF
THE COLLEAGUES OF- I HAVE ASKED
A LOT OF THE THINGS I'VE WANTED
TO SO LET ME MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS AND THEN MAYBE ASK A
QUESTION. AND THE COMMENTS WERE
ON SOME OF THE THINGS YOU'VE
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT. AND BOB
WITH REGARD TO THE QUESTION THAT
SENATOR BATES ASKED WITH REGARD
TO THE SALARIES OF CHANCELLOR'S
I KNOW THAT WE TALKED TO THE-
THE PRESIDENT THE UNIVERSITY AND
HE DID A SIMILAR THING THAT YOU
JUST DID WHAT SHE CITED THE
SALARY STUDY. AND I PROJECTS
REMINDED HIM THAT THERE WILL BE
SALARY STUDIES FOR EVERY OTHER
LEVEL AND I HOPE YOU'RE PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE OTHER SALARY
STUDIES. OF THAT ARE DONE
WITHIN. THE CAMPUS AS WELL THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE WOULD. AND I
THINK SENATOR COM LONGER ASKED
ABOUT THE HOSPITAL'S ISSUE. AND
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE MORE
COMPLEX AND THERE'S A CHANCE
THAT WE MIGHT. MEET WITH YOU AND
BRING YOU UP TO SPEED BECAUSE IT
WAS A PROBLEM WITH WHAT WAS
GOING ON AT THE HOSPITALS AND
RICHARD PEREZ- NEGOTIATED A
SOLUTION THAT THE REGENTS
ADOPTED IN LIEU OF A BILL THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND I THINK IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO JUST. MAKE IT
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T COME ON AFTER
SOME OF THAT HAPPENED AND IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO MAKE SURE.%
YOU'RE UP TO SPEED. A. N. ON
MILLS COLLEGE I THINK MANY OF US
IN PARTICULAR ON THE EDUCATION
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE. WE'RE
LOOKING AT EXACTLY THE PROBLEM
THAT SENATOR CALM WATER
REFERENCED WITH REGARD TO
ENROLLMENT. BAND THE- AND WE END
OUR CONVERSATION TALKED ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS JUST BEEN JAMMING
EVERY EXTRA STUDENT INTO THE
EXISTING FORTY PRINT DINNER
NEEDS TO BE A LONG TERM PLAN AND
ONE OF THE PLANS WAS IF MILLS ON
ITS OWN ON THE DECISION OF MILLS
COLLEGE DECIDED TO GO OUT OF
BUSINESS THAT WAS A READY MADE
CALL CAMPUS TO CORPORATION TO.
RECORDING ENTER AND CAPACITY FOR
MOMENT AND I THINK THAT'S- R.
WHERE THAT STOOD. AND GIVEN THE
FACT EVERYBODY ASKED EVERYTHING
. I THINK I WOULD JUST DO A
DIFFERENT TERM. ON YOUR
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCES AND JUST
ASK YOU- HOW IS YOUR OWN STORY
GOING TO INFORM YOU WHEN YOURS
SITTING HERE MAKING THE
DECISIONS ABOUT ACCESS AND KEPT
IT. AND HOW APPLIED THE
UNIVERSITY EDUCATION IS OUR HOW
WAS THAT EXPERIENCE CAN INFORM
YOU AS A REJECTED AND WHAT YOUR
ACTIONS ARE. WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH US A SIMILAR FOR THAT-
INSIGHTFUL QUESTION AND YOU KNOW
I I'VE BEEN A BLESSED MAN
SENATOR IN THE SENSE THAT- I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY SAID HAD
CERTAIN DOORS OPEN CERTAIN
PEOPLE MENTORS HELPED ME ALONG
THE WAY AND I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO GET YOUR FOOT IN THE
DOOR WHEN I FIRST WORKED AT
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE NATIONAL LAB
. IN TRUTH I MEAN THROUGH AND
AFFIRMING. ACTION DIVERSITY
OFFICE- THE MY DEPARTMENT WAS
ENDING PAIN FOR MYSELF WHEN THEY
WERE GIVING ME FREE OF CHARGE-
BECAUSE- IT WAS THE SPECIAL
PROGRAM TO ALLOW- PEOPLE OF
COLOR TO COME INTO THE LAB AND
WORK AS A SUMMER STUDENT. HAD
THAT PROGRAM NEVER EXISTED I
WOULD HAVE NEVER HAD BEEN ABLE
TO SET MY FOOT. ON AT THE
NATIONAL LAB AND DO THE GOOD
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE HERE THE
PROJECT THAT I'M MOST PROUD OF-
IS DEVELOPING THAT FULL FIELD
DIGITAL MAMMOGRAPHY SYSTEM FOR
EARLIER DETECTION OF BREAST
CANCER- AN INCREDIBLE DEVICE
THAT HAS SAVED. THOUSANDS IF NOT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF LIVES
SO AS I SIT IN MY POSITION A A
REGION- YOU CAN REST ASSURE
SENATOR THAT I'M GONNA BE
LOOKING AT- IN IN TERMS OF HOW
DO WE CREATE OPPORTUNITIES. TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THAT DOOR OPEN
SO THAT THE STUDENTS GIVING
THEM. SHOW THEIR- AND THAT'S
WHAT I'M GONNA BE WORKING HARD
FOR IT I'M SORRY YOU COULD YOU
COULD- YOU CAN FEEL MY PASSION
BECAUSE IT IS SOMETHING VERY-
THAT I FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT
AND YOU KNOW INCLUDING MY KIDS
YOU KNOW MY YOUNGEST IS GOING
TO. MERCED AND HE'S- MAJOR
INJURING IN MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING AND YOU KNOW IT'S
THESE TYPE OF THINGS THAT SAID
EIGHTY YOU KNOW JUST WORK AND
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO. OPEN THE FOR
THE KIDS MAKE SURE THEY- ARE
ABLE TO SET FOR IN THE DOOR AND
BE A TO. WELL YOU'RE STORING
YOUR PASS SIX WHY GOING TO BE A
GREAT PLEASURE TO VOTE TO
CONFIRM THANK YOU FOR. FOR THAT
MEANINGFUL ANSWER INTO. MAN
PROTECT MY PURCHASE A CHANCE TO
HAVE COST. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED AND OUR- REGION
HERNANDEZ I REALLY DON'T HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS AYE I. THINK
STATION AND A NUMBER OF THE
ISSUES BROUGHT UP. IN ADDITION
TO YOUR OPENING COMMENTS AND WHY
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT. ROLE
THAT YOU GET TO PLAY- I THAT
ENTERS MY QUESTIONS I WOULD JUST
NOTE. I THINK KEVIN YOUR VOICE
AT THE TABLE- I HAVE SERVED AS A
UC REGENT. WHEN I WAS THE
SPEAKER FOR A BRIEF A COUPLE
YEARS. AND HAVEN'T THE FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE GRADUATE
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS YOUR
HISTORY. AND THAT OF YOUR FAMILY
IS REALLY IMPORTANT- THE SYSTEM.
IS THE BEST IN THE WORLD AND
THESE ARE. BIG I CAN. A LOT OF.
FOR PATIENT I PLEDGE. IT'S A
LITTLE HARD TO GET THROUGH. THE
SUCH AS LARGE INSTEAD. I WENT TO
A VERY SMALL PRIVATE SCHOOL OUT
WAS A FIRST GENERATION AND I
THINK THAT EXTRA SUPPORT SO THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN PLACE TO
REALLY SUPPORT WELL ALL STUDENTS
FRANKLY BUT- I DO THINK FIRST
GENERATION I STUDENTS. HAVE HAVE
A PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT TIME
I'VE READ THE ARTICLES IN THE
STUDIES ON THAT AT SOME OF OUR
FINEST INSTITUTION SO I HAVE I
KNOW THERE WILL BE A FOCUS AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE BROUGHT TO
THE TABLE THE DISCUSSION TODAY.
YOU'RE AN EXAMPLE TO YOUR YOUR
OWN KIDS OF COURSE BUT I THINK-
OBVIOUSLY TOO YOUNG PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS OUR OUR STATE. AND THE
FAR REACHES THE HAS IT ISN'T
JUST CALIFORNIANS OBVIOUSLY. SO
WITH THAT I THINK I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE- EAT TO BE
HONEST YOU HAVEN'T REALLY HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE THAT
LONG- AND IN THAT TIME FRAME OF-
ZOOMS AS WELL AS TRANSITIONING
BACK TO IN PERSON. IT HAS NOT
BEEN. FOR US- I AM GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND TURN TO THE PUBLIC- SO
WITH MY THANKS I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND TURN TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT MAY BE HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT WE WILL START WITH IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. WE'RE GONNA FLASH THE
OUR PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
UP THERE AGAIN I ON THE SCREEN
SO PEOPLE CAN START TO QUEUE UP
THAT MAY WANT TO PARTICIPATE BY
TELECONFERENCE SO THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
ONE SIX THREE THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO.
AND WITH THAT LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE FROM THE PUBLIC
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE TO HUNDRED I
DO NOT SEE ANYONE IN THE THIS.
WELCOME MANAGER. GREATER WHO IS
WITH THE- CALLS FROM TELE. TODAY
MY ARE YOU PRAY. I AM THANK YOU
LIKE TO GO AHEAD OF THE CODE IS
ONE ZERO IF YOU LIKE TEQUILA.
AND WE WILL ASK THE PEOPLE WHO
SPEAK TO GIVE YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION OUR ORGANIZATION IF ANY
THAT YOU REPRESENT AND YOUR-
POSITION OF SUPPORT GO AHEAD MR
MODERATOR. AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND THERE'S NO
ONE HERE THANK YOU WE'LL BE BACK
WITH YOU IN JUST A MOMENT I'M
SURE- WE WILL COME BACK INTO
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND I STILL
SEE THAT NO ONE IS APPROACH AND
THE- THE DIET SO- MISTER
MODERATOR WILL YOU QUEUE PEOPLE
UP TO SPEAK WHO MAY WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
APPOINTMENT. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO. SPEAK ON OPPOSITION OUR
VISION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THERE IS NO ONE I
CAN'T. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
WILL TALK WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT
LATER AND LET ME GO AHEAD AND
BRING IT BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION-
SENATOR GROWTH HAS MADE A MOTION
TO CONFIRM- AND MOVE THE
APPOINTMENT FORWARD MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROWTH AYE GROVE AYE
KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER I'D LAYERED
ON A LAYERED I'D FACE ALL RIGHT
BATES AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS FIVE
FIVE TWO ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO OUR
REGION HERNANDEZ CONGRATULATIONS
WE WILL MOVE YOUR CONFIRMATION.
TO THE SENATE FLOOR- SO WITH OUR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
HAVE A GREAT DAY. YOU TOO BYE
BYE BYE BYE- WILL CONTINUE NOW
ON ITEMS ONE B. AND C. UNDER
GOVERNORS OF MAINTENANCE-
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
THIS WILL BE THE APPOINTMENTS OF
MEMBERS TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY BOARD OF TRUSTEES SO
WE'RE GOING OVER TO THE OTHER.
SIDE STATE INSTITUTION OF. AN
WITH US TODAY. YEAH LOPEZ. YEAH
ME ROAD- WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU
TRUST THESE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- AND I WOULD INVITE YOU
TRUSTY LOPEZ TO START AN
TECHNOLOGY THANK ANYONE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A AND THEN I WILL TURN TO
TRUSTEE RODRIGUEZ TO DO THE VERY
SAME SO WITH THAT WELCOME AND
MISS LOPEZ GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY. AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF OF COMMITTEES
PERSONAL STAFF THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE SPENT TIME ON THIS AND
THEY'VE HAD A GREAT MEETING WITH
YOUR SO GO. HELLO START BY
THANKING MY WIFE AND LYFT FOR.
AND ALL RIGHT WHO'S NOT HERE SHE
- OF THE DOING THINGS THAT I
DON'T. CAN BE HERE. BUT SHE IS
THE BIG FORTY MY LIFE AND SO ON
A- NOTED THAT- WOULD BE PRETTY
MUCH REMARKS I JUST WANT TO TELL
YOU WHY THIS. AND BRUCE BRIEF
JUST I WHAT I TO SHE HAS BOARD.
OF SPENT THAT MY PROFESSIONAL
AND WORKING INSTEAD GOVERNMENT
INCLUDING THE- CALIFORNIA WONDER
. AT AND THE HALF FROM FOR HIM
TO BE AND ALL WORKING ON THE
ISSUE- OPERA. IN OUR WITH. NOW I
SPEND ABOUT THE LAW FIFTY YEARS
ON AS- ISSUES YOU AND CAL. THE
REALLY FOCUSED ON IT BECAUSE OUT
AND IMPROVING COLLEGE
GRADUATIONS. AND DURING THAT
TIME I WORKED WITH EDUCATORS
ADVOCATES COMMUNITY GROUPS
SUPPORTERS SEPARATELY ANDERS-
THE GAMUT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
REALLY COMMITTED TO INCREASING
COLLEGE ACCESS ACCESS. AND
SUCCESS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THE ONE THING THAT IS REALLY
CLEAR WHEN YOU DO THIS IS HOW
CENTRAL. ZERO SHE WAS THE
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND TO WHICH FUTURE
ECONOMIC VITALITY. WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
CSU GRADUATES ARE THE LARGEST
SOURCE OF PROFESSIONAL HUMAN
CAPITAL IN CALIFORNIA HANFORD
TEACHERS ENGINEERS NURSES OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE BUSINESS LEADERS
AB PUBLIC SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
LEGISLATORS. ANY ROOM THAT YOU
GO INTO IF YOU HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND HE HAS COME IN YOUR
US YES YOU WILL BE SURPRISED HOW
MANY PEOPLE RAISE THEIR HANDS.
THE OTHER THING ABOUT THIS YEAR
IS A IS ALSO THE END FOR IN.
ECONOMIC AND THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL IN THE STATE WERE
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THE STUDENTS
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS TODAY. ARE
CATEGORIZED AS SOCIAL ECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGE THEY NEED CSU AS A
LADDER FOR UP FOR UPWARD
MOBILITY. I CARE HOW CSU WORKS
OUT FULFILLS ITS MISSION ALAMEDA
ITS COMMITMENTS TO ITS STUDENTS
AND ALL OF ITS STAKEHOLDERS AND
THAT'S WHY ONE OF THE
INTERESTING. I WANT TO BE PART
OF WHAT HAPPENS NEXT I WANT TO
HELP ME TO CHALLENGES AND TAKE
ADVANTAGES. OF ALL THE OPERA. SO
WHAT DO I BRING TO THE
APPOINTMENT- HELLO FOR MY RESUME
BUT I'LL TELL YOU THE BY
TRAINING AND THIS POSITION ON A
POLICY WONK. BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE
THINK THIS IS A GOOD THING OTHER
THINGS SO MUCH. I WAS A THE YEAH
FOR I CAN IT WILL UPDATE I LOVE
ANALYZE PROBLEMS FROM LOVED
ABOUT BEING OUT. BUT IN MY HEART
I'M A PROBLEMS. AND I LIKE TO
MAKE A TO HAVE A MAKE AN IDEA
BECOME A REALITY. YOU TAKE A
GOOD. SOLUTIONS AND HELP DELIVER
ON ITS PROMISES. I KNOW IT WOULD
TAKE SOME THINGS IN OUR- I WOULD
A LARGE PROBABLY AGENCY AND
PRIVATE FOUNDATIONS. AND WITHOUT
THE TEAM TO IMMODEST I THINK
BOTH PLACES WERE BETTER OFF WHEN
I LEFT AND WHEN I STARTED. THIS
FINALLY ON A PERSONAL I THOUGHT
OF HIM AS HE- BUT IDENTIFY THE
STUDENTS I'VE MET OVER THE- I AM
NOT THE FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO GO
TO COLLEGE. I'M AN IMMIGRANT.
AND COLUMBIA WERE I'M FROM
COLLEGE WAS FOR BORDERS NOT FOR
GIRLS GIRLS ARE JUST SUPPOSED TO
GET MARRIED. I CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY FIFTEEN WITH MY MOTHER
MY SISTER AND MY MOTHER. I GUESS
STARNES REALLY ALWAYS SAID I
SHOULD GO TO COLLEGE. BUT I JUST
HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN. I ENROLLED IN A PUBLIC
SCHOOL I WANT TO A COUNSELOR AND
HE WAS NOT HEALTH. BUT
FORTUNATELY THERE ARE OTHER
DON'T INCLUDING A TEACHER WILL
MEAN DIED MY WAY INTO COLLEGE.
MONEY WAS ALWAYS ISSUE. MY
EDUCATION WAS PAID FOR BY
SCHOLARSHIPS WORK STUDY SUMMER
JOBS LOANS I WONDER HOW MY GOING
TO GIVE ME AND IT'S REALLY THAT
START IN LIFE VENTURA I'M HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY NOW THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AND IDEALLY BETTER
ONES FOR THE CURRENT OF THE NEXT
GENERATION. CALIFORNIANS FOR
FOUR DAYS YOUR AND HAVING A GOOD
DISCUSSION THIS THIS AFTERNOON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT- FOR SHARING THAT WITH
US A TRUSTEE RODRIGUEZ GO AHEAD
. WELCOME THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AN HONORABLE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- FIRST- I WANT
TO GIVE GRATITUDE- TO MY MEXICAN
IMMIGRANT PARENTS WHO INSTILLED
IN ME THE VALUE HARD WORK AND
PERSEVERANCE- MY FATHER IS FROM
THE TRUCK GUN AND MY MOTHER IS
FROM FORTY PEOPLE AND- I KNOW
THAT MY MOTHER IS WATCHING AND
MY FATHER IS WATCHING FROM
HEAVEN AS WE LOST HIM AND- HE-
MY HUSBAND- IS JOINING US TO-
ONLINE AND- HE IS THE CFO OF. A
FRESNO EOC- I'M ALSO A PROUD CSU
ALONG AS MYSELF. AND MY CHILDREN
JULIET'S AND THE SETS ARE IN
SCHOOL BUT WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
MORNING AND HOW IMPORTANT THIS
WAS FOR THEIR FUTURES. I WAS
BORN IN REDWOOD CITY AND I MOVED
TO TULARE COUNTY AS A YOUNG
PERSON. I UP I ASSURE MY
APPRECIATION AND ALSO TO OUR
GOVERNOR WHO. WANTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE WAS AN APPOINTMENT
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
REPRESENTED ON THIS BOARD. THIS
AGREEMENT HAS SUCH INCREDIBLE
SIGNIFICANCE TO ME AND MY HIGHER
EDUCATION EDUCATION EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE IT WAS SO MEANINGFUL MY
PARENTS SUPPORTED AND VALUED
HIGHER EDUCATION BUT DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO MANEUVER THE SYSTEM. I AM
A FIRST GENERATION GRADUATE WHO
NEEDED THE COLLEGE READINESS
SUPPORTS AND THERE WASN'T
COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS PROGRAMS AT
MY SCHOOL. I'M OR CANCERS TO
SUPPORT ME- BUT CSU FRESNO GAVE
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ENGAGED- I WAS A TRANSFER
STUDENT AND BECAUSE OF. THE
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE THAT I HAD
OF MY COMMUNITY COLLEGE I WAS
ABLE TO TRANSFER- AND BE A
BUSINESS MAJOR AT CSU FRESNO. AS
A YOUTH DEVELOPMENT. AND AFTER
WORKING WITH YOUNG PEOPLE FOR
THE PAST TWO DECADES IN THE
NONPROFIT AND HIGHER EDUCATION
SECTOR I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE
NEED THAT MANY STUDENTS
ENCOUNTER. THROUGH THEIR
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEYS- WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT WITHOUT THE
GUIDANCE- IT'S JUST CRUCIAL FOR
US AS A SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THOSE. PATHWAYS FOR OUR
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO ATTAIN
THEIR EDUCATION. ONLY UNTIL I
KNEW HOW TO MANEUVER THAT SYSTEM
DID I BRING OTHERS ALONG WITH ME
MY SISTERS MY COUSINS MY FRIENDS
AND THEN MY MOM. WHO ENTERED AS
A REENTRY STUDENT IN HER FIFTIES
I'M SO PROUD OF HER. PURSUING
IT. CATION WAS SO MEANINGFUL
BECAUSE I KNEW THAT IT WAS GOING
TO OPEN DOORS FOR OTHERS-
EQUITABLE COLLEGE ENROLLMENT FOR
PEOPLE IN ALL WALKS OF LIFE IS
IMPORTANT TO ME WHICH INCLUDES
STREAMLINING PROCESSES FOR OUR
STUDENTS FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PATHWAYS ARE OPEN FOR
RESTORATION LOW INCOME
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
STUDENTS AND ALL CALIFORNIANS.
STUDENT SUCCESS OF THE TOP
PRIORITY FOR ME. WHEN ALL CSU
STUDENTS DESERVE A QUALITY
EDUCATION WITH INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMMING TO PREPARE THEM FOR
AN EVER EVOLVING WORKFORCE. I
KNOW THIS IS A REAL I'M CRUCIAL
TIME TO BE- AND APPOINT AN
APPOINTED PERSON I KNOW THAT IS
A JOURNEY THAT I DON'T TAKE
LIGHTLY- I FEEL THAT BURDEN WHEN
I GO AND VISIT THE CAMPUSES I'VE
ALREADY BEEN ABLE TO VISIT FIVE
CAMPUSES TO MEET WITH STUDENTS-
AND I KNOW THAT I AM READY FOR
THE CHALLENGE AND IF CONFIRMED I
WILL. WORK EXTREMELY HARD TO
REPRESENT OUR STATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE
COMMENTS THAT WAS- I THINK WE'VE
- BEEN FORTUNATE TO GET SOME
INCREDIBLE STORIES AND- COMMENTS
TODAY FROM SOME INCREDIBLE
APPOINTMENTS- LET ME AGAIN START
WITH OUR VICE CHAIR AND WILL
WILL GO THAT WAY GOD AS WE DID
BEFORE AND I WOULD SAY WE HAVE
TWO TRUSTEES WITH US SO YOU CAN
EITHER DIRECT YOUR QUESTION TO A
PARTICULAR TRUSTEE. OR YOU CAN
ASK BOTH TRUSTEES- TO RESPOND I
WILL LEAVE THAT TO THE TO THE
SENATOR TO DECIDE. MINUTEMAN
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU. I'M I
THINK YOU I'M M. PROTEOMIC ONDO
THANK YOU BOTH ON THIS LOCALES
MISS RODRIGUEZ SOPH OBVIOUSLY
THE PASSION FOR YOUR JOB AND
YOUR APPOINTMENT TO COME THROUGH
AND ACTUALLY- PUTS A LITTLE LUMP
IN A COUPLE OF OUR THROAT
FIGHTING CODE TO SEE THE PASSION
THAT FAIR AND YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO SERVE IN A USER DIFFICULT
TIME SO CERTAINLY IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN TERMS OF
WHAT OUR STUDENTS ARE FACING
WITH HOUSING AND FOOD AND TRYING
TO GET THROUGH ENOUGH WHAT IS IT
FIVE YEARS SIX YEARS AND ALL OF
THAT OUT FULL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL YOU DO I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS IN. MIND
PROBABLY RELATES TO THE- TO BE A
YEAR. THAT I WAS IN CALL. IN TRY
TO GET IN HIGH SCHOOL GET TO
CALL. THAT WAS GOAL AND YOU KNOW
YOU DIDN'T OUT FOR YOU. TO GO TO
TRADE SCHOOL AND MAYBE THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN SUCH A BAD IDEA
ABOUT TIME ANYWAY. I KNOW
ELEKTRISCHE AND WAS MAKING TWICE
AS MUCH AS FRIEND OF MINE WHO'D
GONE AND GOTTEN HIS MASTER'S
DEGREE SO. IF IF THE DIFFERENT
TIME HOWEVER AND I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT. THE ELIMINATION OF THE
FAT AND ASKED FOR ADMISSIONS-
WONDERING. YOU ASSESS IT.
STUDENTS AND THEY'RE READYNAS
LET'S TALK ABOUT MATURITY AND
READY ENOUGH. FOR YOU KNOW
JUMPING FROM HIGH SCHOOL INTO.
WHAT'S REALLY VERY DEMANDING
SCHEDULE IN YOUR FRESHMAN YEAR.
AND I THINK THE MOST
DEMORALIZING THING THAT CAN
HAPPEN TO. FIRST YEAR OF STUDENT
IN COLLEGE IS THEY DON'T MAKE IT
AND THAT HAPPENED TO A FEW OF- I
WOULDN'T SAY FRIENDS BUT
COLLEAGUES WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE
THEY DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGH
THEIR FRESHMAN YEAR THEY JUST
THEY JUST THEY WE WERE TAKING
THE SAT AT THAT TIME BUT- NOT TO
DEBATE THAT JUST. GIVE ME YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT AND HOW YOU DO
A SELF AND THEN WHEN YOU SEE
STUDENTS THAT MAYBE NEED THAT
AFTER SUPPORT. WHAT IS ART WHAT
ARE OUR- UNIVERSITIES PROVIDING
AND ARE THEY PROVIDING SOMETHING
SO THAT THEY CAN CATCH THOSE
LIKE THE SAFETY NET I GUESS IS
WHAT I'M TALKING. BECAUSE I
WOULD HOPE. THAT THAT THERE'S
SOME PLANNING AND OUT TO ENSURE
THAT. SOMEONE DOESN'T YOU KNOW
DROP OUT- FILTERS THEME AGAIN IS
FULL SO VERY IMPORTANT IN THAT
AGE RANGE SO. WELL AND THAT
QUESTIONS FOR BOTH OF YOU I'M
SURE YOU BOTH HAVE. A
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT. THANK YOU
ARE TRUSTEE LOPEZ WHY DON'T YOU
GO FIRST THIS TIME AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO MS RODRIGUEZ AND
WE'LL SWITCH IT UP NEXT TIME.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION IS A GREAT QUESTION AND
I'M PORTANT QUESTIONS- I THINK
IT'S A G. F. AS A TEASE- HAVE
BEEN A PART OF A- COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS AND QUESTIONS FOR SO
LONG I AND- BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS WE LEARNED THAT THE S.
A. T. SENATE ISSUE. S. AND THE.
A. C. T. IT'S- REALLY A SENSE
THAT BEING. AS GOOD PREDICTORS
OF COLLEGE SUCCESS AS THEY ONCE
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE THEY WERE
NOT THE LEVELLERS IF YOU WILL.
OF THE MERIT LEVELERS OF THEY
WERE UP HOW DID TO BE. AND IN
FACT WHAT HAPPENED- OVER TIME IS
THAT CERTAIN GROUPS IN
PARTICULAR GROUPS FROM A LOWER
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED GROUPS.
WERE REALLY ARE NOT DOING THAT
WELL AND IN A SENSE EXACERBATING. INEQUITIES IN COLLEGES AND-
THE BEST PREDICTOR OF HOW STUPID
WILL DO IN COLLEGE REALLY IS FOR
HIGH SCHOOL- RECORD FOR HIGH
SCHOOL TRANSCRIPTS AND HOW THEY
DO. AND SO WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW
WITH THE CSU AS YOU KNOW WE DID
A WOMAN LIKE THE SAT AND- IN THE
A. C. T. I. IT ALONE IT. WILL AT
THE AT THE HIGH SCHOOL- DATA
TRANSFERS THE THREE G. COMPLETE
COMPLETIONS AND THEN TO YOUR
POINT THERE IS THE ADMISSION
PROCESS FROM THEN THE PLACEMENT
PROCESS HOW. HOW DOES THE SCHOOL
NO. WHERE THAT STUDENT WIDELY BE
BEST PLACE FOR THEY REALLY
SHOULD SO THEY DON'T. SO THE
THEY DON'T OF. FIND THEMSELVES
AGAINST THE OBSTACLES OF EITHER
MATH OR ENGLISH WHICH OF THE
TWO- SORT OF GATEWAY COURSES. OF
THE UNIVERSITY HAS MULTIPLE WAYS
OF ASSESSING THAT. ARE SOME OF
THEM ARE STILL STANDARDIZED TEST
OF THE STUDENT TAKES A
STANDARDIZED TEST THE GOVERNMENT
OR USE THAT. BUT IF YOU WERE TO
GO TO THEIR WEBSITE YOU WILL SEE
THAT THERE'S A WHOLE SYSTEM
THERE THAT ENTERING STUDENTS CAN
USE TO ASSESS AND TO SORT OF SEE
WHERE THE PLACE. AND THEN BASED
ON THE SELF ASSESSMENT THEY CAN
THINK AND TALK TO THEIR GUIDANCE
COUNSELORS AND THEN THEY HAVE A
WHOLE BUNCH OF ARCHED OF SCORING
THE CLASSES WITH. WERE STRONG
COLLEGE IN THE SUMMER BEFORE OR
DOING WHATEVER IT TAKES THIS.
THE MAIN OF WITH THE KERN WITH
THE- IS DOING IS.
THEY SPEND THE MOST LASSEN. SO
YEAH OUR- THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M
YES I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO IS A
SYSTEM IS BE PREPARED TO ASSIST
THOSE STUDENTS- FOR THEIR
PLACEMENT AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'VE DONE- PART OF THE
MULTI FACTOR MISTER PROCESS- IS
TO DETERMINE YOU KNOW BASED ON
THEIR FORCES LIKE- ADDRESSING OF
THE SAID BASED ON THEIR GPA-
THAT IF THEY NEED TO ENROLL IN
WHAT'S CALLED AN EARLY START
PROGRAM THEY CAN ACTUALLY TAKE
THAT PROGRAM IN THE SUMMER.
PRIOR TO THEM ATTENDING IN THE
FALL AND ALL OF OUR TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES ACTUALLY OFFER THAT
EARLY START PROGRAM AND IT WAS
DESIGNED TO DEVELOP COLLEGE
RIGHT READY MISS BEFORE THEY
ENROLL IN SCHOOL WHICH I THINK
IS CRUCIAL- I FEEL YOU KNOW MY
STORY BEING FROM A RURAL
COMMUNITY AND ON A SMALLER
SCHOOL THAT THE NECESSARY.
RESOURCES I WHAT- INFORMED OR
PREPARED EVEN SHARED WHEN THE-
OR ACT DEAD WORST I DIDN'T GET
TO TAKE THAT. THEM THROUGH THE
WAS MY STORY AND I KNOW THAT
MANY- STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE
A PARTICULARLY YOU KNOW
EXPERIENCE THAT. SO AS A SYSTEM
WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THOSE IN PLACE SO THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE JUST READY TO
GO WHEN THEY START IN THE FALL.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT NOW TO
THE QUESTION ON BOTH OF YOU
CONFIDANTE WHEN I SAW IT IT WAS
TROUBLING ON JUST KNOWING A FEW
RELATE TO KIDS GOING INTO
KINDERGARTEN SOMETIMES THEY'RE
JUST NOT READY RIGHT. AND ON
THAT SAME THING AS WE MATURE
ALONG THE WAY FROM SOME ARE VERY
SMART BUT MAYBE NOT READY FOR
THE PRESSURES THAT COME. IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU DO HAVE. AN
ATTENTION TO THAT AND CERTAINLY
ARE WITHOUT EARLY START I WOULD
SAY THAT FOR. MAYBE A SAFETY
NET. THAT FOR THEIR FIRST BEFORE
SOMEONE ELSE MIGHT YOU KNOW HAVE
HAVE AN ISSUE ONCE THEY'RE THERE
I JUST ONE LAST QUESTION I KNOW-
ON. THEIR ON THE IMPROVING THE
GRADUATION RATES FOR FRESHMEN
AND RANSFER STUDENTS HAS REALLY
BEEN AN INITIATIVE IN THE FOLK
OF. THAT MY STAFF INFORMATION
TELLS ME THERE'S STILL GAPS IN
THE BUDGET WITH ACTION RATES FOR
LOW INCOME. AND UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS THOUGHT YOU'VE
PERSISTING IN QUESTION FOR BOTH
OF YOU AGAIN ON ARE WE FOCUSING
ON THAT IN IN ON TRYING TO
DETERMINE WHAT. WITH CUTTING OUT
WHAT THE GAP IS THAT MIGHT GO TO
THE READY NOW AGAIN OR OR WHAT
SCHOOL TO COME OUT OF WHAT-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE KIND. OF IN
THERE THEY HAD THE IN DEPTH- IN
IN ENGLISH OR- MATH THIRTY
NEEDED BUT- HERE'S YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT- TRUSTEE RODRIGUEZ ONE
OF YOU A- SOFTENED WILL GO BACK
TO TWO MISS LOPEZ. I ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- I. AM REALLY ME
SURE I WAS A OF AND- HAS IN.
PEOPLE I START. ON SEVEN EIGHT
MONTHS AGO- IS- SEES FIVE POINT
- EQUITY. ON REALLY MAKING SURE
THAT. THERE PRACTICES SUPPORTS A
RESOURCES FOR STUDENTS THAT NEED
THAT ADDITIONAL HELP. SO THAT WE
CAN HELP THEM GRADUATE. ON TIME.
AND AND I THINK THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW THERE'S
DEFINITELY THINGS THAT WE HAVE
TO PUT IN PLACE. TO HELP THEM-
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT IS- LIKE OUR
FIRST PRIORITY IS MAKING SURE
THAT WE RE ENGAGE- ARE UNDER
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS AT
POTENTIALLY STOPPED OUT. BECAUSE
OF CODE I MEAN THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE REALLY MAKE SURE- IS-
TOP OF MIND FOR US TO. ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO RE
ENROLL. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
I'M REALLY PROUD TO- TO EITHER.
IS THAT IT'S INCREDIBLE THAT OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE JUST MAKING SO
MANY DIFFERENT- OF PROGRAMS TO
BE ABLE TO. REACH OUT TO THOSE
I. JUST IF YOU BAKER SPILLED AND
THE- WITH ME HOW. THEY ARE DOING
THIS REALLY INTENSIVE- COUNCIL
APPROACH ABLE TO CONNECT WITH
THOSE STUDENTS- AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE GET BACK INTO THE
SYSTEM SO THEY CAN GET BACK ON
TRACK. AND OTHER THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO PROCESS IS AYE IS THERE
ANY OTHER BARRIERS
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS FOR THE
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO- A TEEN-
THEIR GRADUATION ON TIME. AND WE
NEED TO REVISE THOSE AND I KNOW
THAT ALL OF OUR INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUSES ARE DOING THAT- AND AS
I GO TO THE DIFFERENT CAMPUSES I
ASKED THEM. ON THOSE QUESTIONS
AND- THEY ARE TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE CREATING
THESE. PIECES FOR THEIR STUDENTS
AND TO GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES-
WHICH I THINK IS VALUE APPLE AND
REALLY A- THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT- THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION I THE JUST THAT WITH
PROCEDURE WAS I WAS SPEAKING TO.
UNDERSCORE THE EQUITY CLOSING
THOSE EQUITY GAPS IS THE MAJOR
FOCUS OF THE ENTIRE SYSTEM AND
HAS BEEN FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS. AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE. I IN
ADDITION TO THE THINGS THAT THE
TRUSTEE RODRIGUEZ A JUST A
COUPLE OF OTHER- OF THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING THAT I THINK WILL
HELP SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
SENATE POST SOME OF THESE EQUITY
GAS. ONE OF HIS SONS UNDER SOME
SOME UNIVERSITIES SOME CAMPUSES
ARE DOING REALLY WELL AND OTHERS
NOT SO WELL AS YOU AS YOU
MENTIONED SENATOR. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE SYSTEM IS
ORGANIZING IS IN A SENSE SUPPORT
GROUPS ON LEARNINGS FROM EACH
OTHER. WHAT WORKED IN ONE CAMPUS
WHAT WERE THE LESSONS THERE HOW
CAN THEY APPLIED IN ANOTHER IN
ANOTHER CAMPUS SO THEY'RE
BEGINNING TO SHARE. LESSONS
LEARNED AND WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN'T AND HOPEFULLY. ROOF
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. I THINK ALL
THE CAMPUSES ARE IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
AND SUPPORT EFFECTIVE TRUSTED
REVIEWS THAT ARE DOING THINGS
LIKE IDENTIFYING IN THEIR
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES FOR EXAMPLE
WHAT ARE THE COURSES ONE OF THE
COURSES THAT ARE IN RECENT
SURVEY LANG IN LARGE NUMBERS WHY
ARE THEY FAILING IN LARGE
NUMBERS TYPICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS. WHAT
HAS TO HAPPEN IS THAT THE
PEDAGOGY IS OF THIS OF COURSE
YOU KNOW REALLY TAKING A GOOD
HARD LOOK AT UNDERSTANDING WHAT
IS IT ISN'T THAT IT'S THE
STUDENTS FAULT OF THEIR FAILING
IS THAT THEY HAVE TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS AND
MAINTAINING THE QUALITY OF
TEACHING AND LEARNING BUT AT THE
SAME TIME ADJUSTING TO MEET WITH
THE STUDENTS ARE AT AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT. THE OTHER
THING TO GET TO HOLDING SOME OF
THOSE EQUITY GAPS IS STUDENTS
WHOSE PARENTS ABOUT THE COLLEGES
CRUSHER IS MISSING AND I SPEAK
FOR MYSELF. AS WELL MY MOTHER
DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE. YOU KNOW
YOU GO COLLEGE ANY JUST ARE SORT
OF WHY. AROUND YOU KNOW AND NOW
WE HAVE PATHWAY. AND WE HAVE A
TO TELL STUDENTS IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN DOING THAT THIS IS
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO EVERY YEAR
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THE OTHER
IMPORTANT THINGS COLLEGES RETURN
UNIVERSITIES ARE DOING IS.
SCHEDULING SO THAT THERE ARE
CLASSES. AVAILABLE SO THEY CAN
MEET ALL THE REQUIREMENTS SO
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM. ARE VERY
. NITTY GRITTY THINGS ARE GOING
ON ACROSS THE CAMPUSES. WE HAVE
WORK TO DO THERE'S IMPROVEMENT
TO BE DONE TO BE DONE BUT I CAN
SAY THAT IN IN THE TIME TAT
I'VE BEEN- ON THE ON THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES ON THE REPORTS SO WE
FOR. THERE'S A REAL COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT. LIKE
WITH THE- AS FAR AND RE THOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE OF COMMENTS
A BOTH ON ARE ACTUALLY READ.
SIDE T BE ON THOSE BOARDS IN
TERMS OF YOUR OWN BACKGROUND IN
AGAIN YOUR COMMITMENT TO EACH
AND EVERY STUDENTS WOULD. BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE ON THEIR FOUR
YEAR FIVE YEAR SIX YEAR. DEGREE
AND BE OUT IN THE WORLD-
CONTRIBUTING AND CERTAINLY OF
BEING ON THEIR THEIR CAREER
PATHS THANK YOU AND YOU WILL
BOTH HAVE MY STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAMVICE HERE LET ME
TURN TO SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU
MA'AM PRO TEM I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
LADIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY COME
BEFORE US- I DO I WOULD LIKE TO
START- WITH MISS RODRIGUEZ. AT
THE END THE ONLY REASON I'M
STARTING WITH YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ
IS BECAUSE I'M VERY GRATEFUL
THAT THE GOVERNOR PICK SOMEBODY
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS OFTEN OVER
OVERLOOKED. AND WE ARE YOU KNOW
WHERE THE TOP THREE FOOD
PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE WORLD.
AND WE PRODUCE 70% OF THE FUEL
AND 58% OF THE- RENEWABLE ENERGY
AND I JUST THINK IT'S- A GOOD
MOVE TO PUT SOMEBODY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. ON THIS BOARD SO
THAT- WE HAVE REPRESENTATION AND
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO US IS VALLEY
RESIDENTS MAKING SURE THAT. A
LOT OF OUR KIDS HAVE PATHWAYS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. SO HAVING THAT
IN MIND- YOUR OPINION ON OUT CS
YOU CAN BETTER SERVE. THE NEEDS
OF THE STUDENTS IN THE
UNDERSERVED AREAS SUCH AS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY I MEAN. YOU'RE
GOING TO BE THERE ON THE BOARD
GIVING YOUR FIRST HAND KNOWLEDGE
OF- THE PEOPLE THAT SURROUND US
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AREA AND
HOW ARE WE GOING TO EXPAND THEIR
REACH TO HIGHER EDUCATION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR GROWN ON.
ARE YOU PROUD TO BE FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- IT'S HAS GIVEN
SO MUCH TO ME- AND THAT
THROUGHOUT- MY- YOUTH AND ALSO
NOW IN MY CAREER. I WILL TELL
YOU THAT WORKING WITH- STUDENTS-
FOR A GOOD NUMBER OF YEARS YOU
KNOW I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
EXPERIENCE. I'M ON. THEIR
JOURNEYS OF TRYING TO ATTAIN
HIGHER EDUCATION. I AM HARD OF
THE ISSUES THAT I'VE SEEN. IS
THIS COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS
COMPONENT THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT I SYSTEMS THAT WE
TRULY HELP OUR STUDENTS TO BE
PREPARED AND READY FOR COLLEGE-
AND THAT ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS WORK
TOGETHER TO DO THAT- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE- BEEN STRESSING
IS. REALLY WE NEED TO TRY TO
CREATE THIS CULTURE A COLLEGE
GOING CULTURE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES EVEN IF IT'S NOT A
TRADITION AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
HOW DO WE DO THAT. I SHARED
WITH- SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES THAT
TRULY YOU KNOW GETTING YOUR
EDUCATION AND MAKING THAT
DECISION IS REALLY A FAMILIAL
DECISION. SO OW ARE WE AS
INSTITUTIONS MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS THIS- FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
COMPONENT BURKE YOU KNOW OUR
PARENTS ARE A PART OF THE
PROCESS- WITH OUR STUDENTS THAT
THEY ARE KNOWLEDGEABLE IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE FOR ME. YOU
HAVE- IN. FROM THE COLLEGE TO
WALK WITH MY PARA. ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT IT MEANT A TO APPLY
FOR FINANCIAL AID AND TO DO
THOSE DIFFERENT THINGS- MY FIRST
WORK STUDY JOB WAS FINANCIAL
AID. OFFICE I WAS EIGHTEEN YEARS
OLD WORK IN THE FINANCIAL AID
OFFICE WHICH WAS AMAZING.
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY USED THAT
SKILL SET THE HELP ANYONE AROUND
ME TO HELP THEM KNOW HOW TO FILL
OUT THAT APPLICATION I GAVE
WORKSHOPS IN SPANISH AND- IT ALL
KINDS OF THINGS TO JUST TRY TO
ENCOURAGE YOU KNOW MORE OF OUR
STUDENTS. YOU KNOW TO- TO GO FOR
THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATION SO.
THERE REALLY IS WE HAVE TO THINK
CREATIVELY AND INNOVATIVELY TO
SAY HOW DO WE MAKE THIS MORE
ACCESSIBLE. TO THEM TO OUR
STUDENTS BUT ALSO KNOW THAT WITH
MANY OF OUR DIFFERENT CULTURES
THAT ARE IN AND WE'RE STILL
CULTURALLY RICH. US SENATE
APPROVED YOU KNOW THIS- WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
SPACES AVAILABLE FOR THEM. TO
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO GET
A COLLEGE EDUCATION. THANK YOU
MA'AM I APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH. I MISS LOPEZ. YOU KNOW ME
UNITED STATES MILITARY VETERAN
AND WE HAVE OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND MILITARY FAMILIES- THAT
ARE CONNECTED TO OUR STUDENTS-
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE- ON CAMPUSES TO FOSTER
PROMOTE SUPPORTIVE ATMOSPHERE
FOR THE STUDENTS WHOSE PARENTS
MIGHT BE DEPLOYED. SO THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION ARSENE'S THAT
IN SOME OF THE OTHER COLLEGES OR
VISIT US ON THE UNIVERSITIES ARE
VISITED THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
THEIR CENTERS FOR VETERANS AND
VETERANS SERVICES BUT YOU'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE DEPENDENCE AND
I HAVE TO ADMIT ARE A WILL HAVE
TO GET BACK TO YOU ARE A I DON'T
KNOW SPECIFICALLY NOW THAT I CAN%
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION NO THAT'S
OKAY. I THANK YOU MA'AM I DIDN'T
MEAN TO CUT YOU OFF I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT THAT WAS NOT
INTENTIONAL AND EVEN SOMETHING
ANYTHING. THANK YOU. BUT I DO AM
I APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU
ACCEPTING THIS NOMINATION AND
BEING A PART OF THIS INTERVIEW
PROCESS AND- I THINK YOU'RE BOTH
VERY VERY WELL. QUALIFIED LIKE I
SAID I'M EXCITED THAT MISS
RODRIGUEZ COMES FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. N. AND MISS LOPEZ NO NO
OFFENSE MEANT WHATSOEVER BUT YOU
REMIND ME OF MY GRANDMOTHER WITH
AN IRON FIST. THAT IS GOING TO
DO WHAT IT TAKES TO MAKE SURE
THE PEOPLE AROUND HER INCLUDING
HER GRANDCHILDREN ARE SUCCESSFUL
AND I HOPE THAT YOU A- HAVE A
LOT OF ADOPTED GRANDCHILDREN IN
THAT THE UC SYSTEM THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU AND I THINK
THAT IS A COMP OKAY GOOD THING
YOU SENATOR GROVE- SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU MADAM IT'S
TOUGH TO NOT WANT TO COMMENT ON
AND SO WAYS. BUT OF COURSE I'M
NOT GOING TO- IT HAS I SAID
DURING- ARE HEARING OF THE U.
REGENT I THOUGHT THE DISCUSSIONS
WE HAD. IN WITH HIM IN ADVANCE
WERE AMONG SOME OF THE BEST
DISCUSSIONS THAT I'VE HAD WITH.
WITH POTENTIAL CANDIDATESHERE
ON THE RULES COMMITTEE AND I
THINK EXPANDING ON WHAT SENATOR
GROVE SAID. IT'S INTERESTING TO
NOTE THAT ALL THREE OF THE
CANDIDATES OR FROM AN IMMIGRANT
BACKGROUND AND THAT TOO FAR FROM
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND I
THINK THAT IS REALLY SIGNIFICANT
I THINK THAT'S NOT SOMETHING.
WOULD HAVE BEEN TEN OR TWENTY
YEARS AGO BAND. ARE IT IS A
GREAT THING HERE TODAY AND THE
THING I WANTED TO EXPLORE A
LITTLE AND WE HAD A VERY
DETAILED TALK CURRENT EVENTS AT
THE CSU SYSTEM RIGHT NOW HAVE
NOT BEEN. TOTALLY PLEASANT AND I
THINK THAT. THAT WHETHER IT IS
OF THE CURRENT EVENTS IN
CHOOSING A NEW CHANCELLOR. OR
THE OPERATIONS AND THE LABOR
AGREEMENTS MAKING SURE THAT
SOMEBODY IS LOOKING OVER THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE THE
LABOR AGREEMENTS ARE DONE IN A
WAY. THAT IS FAIR AND WORKS FOR
PEOPLE OR THE GRADUATION RATES
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A PROGRAM
THAT HAS ACTUALLY BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN RAISING THE FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATE BUT IT'S
NOT THERE YET. TO WEAR THE GOALS
WERE MET AND MY QUESTION FOR
EACH OF YOU AND I SHOULD NOTE
THAT I HAVE KNOWN JULIO LOPEZ
SAID SHE WAS ARE LEGISLATIVE
STAFFER. THE BOMB HOW DO YOU AND
WE'LL START WITH WITH TRUSTEE
LOPEZ AND THEN GO TO TRUSTEE
RODRIGUEZ. HOW DO YOU AS
TRUSTEES. R. MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ACTUALLY IMPACT THESE ISSUES HOW
DO YOU MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE NOT
DRESSED SORT OF AT A VERY HIGH
LEVEL AND OFFERING OPINIONS HOW
DO YOU MAKE SURE. THAT DID YOU
IMPACT THE OPERATIONS IN IMPACT
THESE ISSUES AND REALLY HELP CSU
ACHIEVE THE GOALS AND MAKES A
DIFFERENCE AND I THINK WE'LL
STARTWITH WITH TRUSTEE LOPEZ.
THANK YOU CENTER RUMORED AS
YOU'RE RIGHT WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
VERY VERY. GREAT DISCUSSION WE
MET. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BOARD IS THE
GOVERNING BODY. HE HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO REALLY ASK.
CRITICAL QUESTIONS. INTO ISSUES
TO ENSURE THE WHEN PROPOSALS
COME TO THE STAFF WE ACTUALLY
ARE NOT ESSENTIALLY EXPECTED TO
APPROVE BUT THAT WE ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE ISSUES ARE
WHAT THE OPTIONS ARE WHAT THE
PROS AND THE CONS ARE. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS I WOULD SAY RIGHT OFF
THE BAT AND TERMS OF HOW THE
BOARD OPERATES- AND PERHAPS FOR
THE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE COMMITTEES AND THE BOARD
STRUCTURES ON THE SOFA AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY DIG INTO
THOSE BIG ISSUES THAT AFFECT.
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE WE'VE GOTTEN
REPORTS WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK. BUT THERE'S A LOT MORE
I SUSPECT THAT WE CAN HAVE IN
TERMS OF HEARINGS OR- COMMITTEE
MEETINGS. WITH THE STAFF THERE
REALLY PRO AND UNDERSTAND AND
THEN SUGGEST HOW WE WOULD EXPECT
TO SEE OR DON'T KNOW ESSENTIALLY
. IMAGE WITH NONE THE BELTWAY IN
A GOOD WAY. HOW CAN WE DO BETTER
AND HOW CAN WE HELP THEM GET
BETTER- AT THE IMPLEMENTATION
LEVEL- THE LABOR AGREEMENTS FOR
EXAMPLE OBVIOUSLY THOSE ARE
NEGOTIATED. BUT I THINK AT THE
BOARD LEVEL AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S IMPORTANT HAS
COME UP BEFORE. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE GOING FAIR
LABOR AGREEMENT SO THAT THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTED APPROPRIATELY. END
TO THE EARLIER DISCUSSION WITH
YOU SEE ABOUT SALARIES THAT THE
SALARIES ARE ALL ACROSS ALL THE
WAY DOWN UP AND DOWN THE LINE.
YOU KNOW WE ARE DOING WE
CERTAINLY HAVE OUR EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION ISSUE THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING UP. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A SALARY STUDY FOR STAFF
AND A SALARY STUDY FOR FACULTY
WE WANT TO BRING SOME EQUITY
ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE BOARD HAS
BEEN VERY CONSISTENT. IT'S NOT
JUST. THE PRESIDENT'S. OR THE
FACULTY OR THE STAFF WE SAID NO
WE HAVE TO GET IT ALL DONE WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT ALL OF THESE AND
THAT IS A PLACE FOR THE BOARD
REALLY ASSERTED ITSELF. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE-
EQUITY IF YOU WILL OPEN DOWN THE
INSTITUTIONS- CHOOSING THE
CHANCELLOR PERHAPS IS THE MOST.
IMPORTANT JOB OF THE BOARD HAS
OUR LOOK THE FREELANCE. I THINK
THAT THE- THE- THERE BEEN SOME
VERY DIFFICULT LESSEN SOME VERY
PAINFUL LESSONS LEARNED.
RECENTLY IN DURING OUR VERY
SHORT TENURE WE WE'VE RUN THEM
VERY QUICKLY. I THINK WE OUGHT
TO TAKE THOSE LESSONS AND MAKE
SURE. THAT AS WE GO INTO THE
PROCESS OF CHOOSING THE NEXT
CHANCELLOR. THAT WE REALLY DO
THAT. WILL TAKE THOSE LESSONS TO
HEART THAT WE DO A VERY THOROUGH
VETTING. THAT WE DO THE KINDS OF
REFERENCE CHECKS. NO MATTER HOW
WELL WE KNOW PREFERRED
CANDIDATES. WE NEED TO NOT TAKE
ANYTHING FOR GRANTED. AND
IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
AND INSISTENT DEMANDS THE BOARD
HAS FULL INFORMATION. BEFORE
MAKES A FINAL DECISION SO THERE
ARE LESSONS TO BE LEARNED THERE
THAT IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT DECISION BECAUSE THAT
LEADERSHIP IN A SENSE WILL SET
THE TONE AND IN THE SENSE OF.
LEAD THE WAY AS WE MOVE FORWARD
SO I'LL STOP THERE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A TRUSTEE RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION AND YOU'RE RIGHT THIS
IS A TIME- IN THE CSU SYSTEM.
WHERE THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
DEFINITELY HAS TO DO THEIR DUE
DILIGENCE- AND NEEDS TO LISTEN
FROM ALL STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
INVOLVED- ON OUR CAMPUSES. AND
ONE OF THE MAIN THINGS THAT I'VE
LEARNED IS IN ORDER FOR ME TO BE
A GOOD DECISION MAKER A GOOD
POLICY MAKER FOR OUR SYSTEM I
HAVE TO HEAR FROM THEM- I'VE-
BEEN ABLE TO VISIT LIKE I SAID
FIVE CAMPUSES AS FAR AND- WIDE
TO DO EVEN MORE- BUT MEETING.
WITH STUDENTS DIRECTLY MEETING
WITH STAFF AND FACULTY DIRECTLY
MEETING WITH OUR ADMINISTRATORS.
REALLY OPENED MY EYES TO THE
UNIQUENESS OF OUR TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES ALSO- AND- AND HOW THEY
SERVE THEIR STUDENTS. BUT ALSO
TO KNOW THE IMPACTS ON THE
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE- ADDING
IT TO WHAT TRUSTEE LOPEZ SAID
ABOUT OUR- MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE- EVERYTHING IN PLACE FOR
THIS NEW COUNSELOR I AM. PLEASED
WITH OUR INTERIM CHANCELLOR WHO
JUST STARTED THIS WEEK WHO HAS
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING- YOU KNOW
TO ENSURE THAT. TRUST IS
RESTORED IN THE SYSTEM- I HAVE
SAID THIS BEFORE THIS IS A TIME
OF RESTORATION. AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE IN THESE
IMPORTANT STEPS TOWARDS HEALING.
AND DO WHATEVER IS NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO DO THAT- WITH THAT
SAID- THERE IS- I AM GLAD TO FOR
AN APPOINTMENT TO BE THE VICE
CHAIR. CHAIR FOR THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE- AND WILL BE ABREAST
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING AND- AND OUR
AUDIT COMMITTEE BUT ALSO- IF YOU
WANT TO- ENCOURAGE YOU KNOW.
MORE WORKING TIME MORE WORKING
COMMITTEE MEETINGS- SO THAT WE
ARE- VERY MUCH AWARE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON WHAT IS HAPPENING- THE
I KNOW THAT UNTRUSTED LOPEZ IS
GOING TO BE VICE CHAIR OF
FINANCE I'M VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD THAT TO THAT ALSO- BUT
WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE LISTENING. TO ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS OUR
ENTIRE CAMPUSES ENTIRE
UNIVERSITIES AND- WE HAVE. A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK TO DO
YOU DEFINITELY DO. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU ANSWERING
THAT QUESTION IN SUCH DETAIL
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
GOING FORWARD ON ALL THESE
ISSUES BECAUSE THERE'S STILL A
LOT TO DO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
. THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED- I
BELIEVE WHEN WE STARTED- BEFORE
THE FIRST APPOINTMENT SENATOR
LAYERED MADE A COMMENT ABOUT.
THE MEETINGS IN THE IN THE BEST
THAT HE'S HAD- WITH BOTH OF YOU
AS WELL AS THE UC REGENT- I
APPOINTEE AND IT'S EASY TO SEE
WHY- YOU ARE- BOTH IN TERMS OF
YOUR EXPERIENCE YOUR-
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE HERE.
EVERYONE HAS A STORY ABOUT HOW
THEY GET TO COLLEGE AND IT AND
IT'S IMPORTANT AND IT'S MEANING
FULL OF FOR THOSE OF US WHO FEEL
FORTUNATE WE GOT TO GO TO
COLLEGE OR HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GO TO COLLEGE WHICH WASN'T
NECESSARILY EXPECTED. I IN I AM
IN THE STORIES ARE SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO BE
REFLECTIVE- WHEN YOU MAKE
DECISIONS THAT IMPACT SO MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR YOUNG
FOLKS WHO WHO JUST WANT A CHANCE
SO- IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN REALLY
ODD DELIGHTFUL FRANKLY TO HEAR
YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW TO APPROACH
SOME PRETTY. DIFFICULT ISSUES AS
I SAID EARLIER I WASN'T UC
REGENT I WAS ALSO A CSU TRUSTEE
AND I COULD SEE THE WORK THAT
WENT INTO THIS AND I COULD SEE
THE PASSION OF THOSE THAT SERVED
ON THE BOARD YOU CLEARLY HAD
SOME DIFFICULT ISSUES. AND YOUR
ANSWERS TO THE QUESTIONS WHETHER
IT'S THE YOU KNOW THE SEARCH FOR
A CHANCELLOR TO ARM HOW TO
APPROACH TESTING AND CREDENTIALS
THINGS- IT'S JUST BEEN REALLY
GOOD TO BE ABLE TO HEAR YOUR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL PROCESS- SO I
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE QUESTIONS.
BUT I SEE THAT A SENATOR COM
LONGER IS HERE AND I WANT TO
GIVE HER THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
SOME QUESTIONS BEFORE WE GO TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC DOES
COME ON I. REMEMBER TEM AND I'M
I WAS- REFLECTING ON MY TIME. AT
A- BOARD TRUSTEE FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT- AND
HEARING FROM SO MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE DURING MY TIME THERE. WHO
ARE WORKING DESPERATELY TO
MATRICULATED INTO EITHER THE CSU
OR THE UC SYSTEM- AND HOW
IMPORTANT THIS- TROIKA IS OR
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL IT
TRIFACTA OF- COLLEGE
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE HAVE THAT
OUR PUBLIC THAT ARE REALLY SO
CRITICAL FOR HOW YOUNG PEOPLE
AND OLDER PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
MOVE UP. I REALLY JUST HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS SB I WAS
INSPIRED BY THE STORIES- THAT I
WAS HEARING FROM THE TWO OF YOU
I'M AN WAS THINKING ABOUT NOT
ONLY IS IT ABOUT WANTING
STUDENTS TO ATTEND AND GRADUATE.
AND HAVE WHAT THEY NEED TO MOVE
THROUGH- BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT YOU HAVE A
WORKFORCE THAT IS DIVERSE- AND
RESPONSIVE BECAUSE THAT IS PART
OF THE ALCHEMY OTHER STUDENT
SUCCESS. PAN ANY OF THAT. THE
WOW MORE THAN THREE OUT OF FOUR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS OUR STUDENTS
OF COLOR JUST BARELY ONE IN
THREE OF THEIR TEACHERS ARE- AND
THAT CAME FROM AN EDUCATION.
TRUST WEST- REPORT AND SO I YOU
KNOW. I WAS THINKING ABOUT SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAD AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT-
IN LA AND SORT OF SOME OF THE
STRATEGIES THAT WE USE TO
DIVERSIFY OUR WORKFORCE. AND
JUST WANTED TO KNOW- FROM. L. IT
BOTH OF YOU I GUESS AND THEN
I'LL JUST HAVE TO BE IT- HOW IS
THE CSU WORKING TO BUILD A
LARGER AND MORE DIVERSE WORK
FORCE- SENATE- TRUSTEE LOPEZ WHY
DON'T YOU TAKE IT FIRST AND THEN
TRUSTEE RODRIGUEZ- THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION I THINK IT'S A
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION
. THE PRIORITY AND IN MY MIND
IT'S SOMETHING IT'S ONE OF THESE
MEDIUM TERM LONG TERM PRIORITIES
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO START.
FOCUSING ON AND SHINING A
SPOTLIGHT TODAY. THERE IS A
DEMOGRAPHIC TRANSITION I DON'T
KNOW THE NUMBERS OR FACTS IN
TERMS OF THE FACULTY AT THE
UNIVERSITY AS A WHOLE. BUT WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF REALLY
GOING THROUGH A TRANSITION. AND
WE HAVE THE HIGHER THE WORK
FORCE FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. THAT REALLY REFLECTS
WHO WERE EDUCATING HIM THE
POPULATION OR LISTEN TO CAN SEE
THEMSELVES. AND THEY ARE IN THE
WORK FORCE AND THEIR PROFESSORS
THAT'S FIXED TERM IMPORTANT. THE
CHALLENGE OF COURSE IS THE
RECRUITMENT AND WHAT OF THE
PIPELINES AND HOW MANY. YOU KNOW
WHAT OF THE PIPELINES TO GET A
PHD IN BECOME A PROFESSOR AT A
COLLEGE. AND SO ON AND SO FORTH
I THINK THAT SHE THIS YEAR
ACTUALLY. IS HAS IS VERY
CONSCIOUS OF THIS WORKING VERY
HARD. ON SEVERAL LEVELS IN TERMS
OF RECRUITING NATIONALLY USING
ALL THE NETWORKS THEY CAN MAKING
SURE THAT THEY USE BEST
PRACTICES. BEING AWARE OF
UNCONSCIOUS BIASES WITH FEDERAL
TO RECRUIT AND REALLY BRING IN A
DIVERSE POOL OF EXISTING
CANNABIS. BUT ALSO DEVELOPING
PIPELINES WE DON'T HAVE THE PHD
PROGRAMS THOSE IN THE UC AND
OTHER. UP HERE WATER WAS A DARK
AND I ALWAYS GET THIS WRONG. THE
RESEARCH ONE INSTITUTIONS. YOU
KNOW BUT CONNECTING THEM. AND I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS OF. THE
TARGET TO SOME OF PRESENT AND
SOME INSTANCES I THINK THE SEALS
. IS L. OFFERS A REAL. ROBUST
OPPORTUNITY TO CONNECT OUR
GRADUATE STUDENTS INTO PHD
PROGRAMS TO BECOME THE WORKFORCE
OF TOMORROW AND I THINK THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT THE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ARE DOING ALREADY.
I THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT- AND
HE SAID THAT THE LAST THING I
JUST WANT TO SAY- JUST MAKE THE
SHORT IS. IT TO BE A PRIORITY
FOR THE BOARD IT HAS TO BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE CHANCELLOR AND
IT HAS TO BE A PRIORITY FOR THE
FOR THE PRESENTS OTHER WORDS IT
HAS TO BE A PRIORITY FOR THE
LEADERSHIP. AND WE NEED TO HOLD
WE NEED TO REVIEW THE PROGRESS
AND WE NEED TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE TO SEEING WHAT
PROGRESS YOU'RE MAKING. SO.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD- TRUSTEE
RODRIGUEZ. AND JUST TO ADD A
LITTLE BIT TOO- WHAT TRUSTEE
LOPEZ SAID- YOU KNOW I THINK-
ONE OF THE UNIQUE CONVERSATIONS
BECAUSE I ASKED THIS QUESTION
WHEN I'VE GONE TO THE DIFFERENT
CAMPUSES AND- YOU KNOW THE
UNIQUE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD
WITH THE CAMPUSES IS YOU KNOW
WHEN. HOW THEY ARE ENCOURAGING
DIVERSITY- ON HIRING COMMITTEES
AND ENSURING THAT YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE FACULTY THAT REPRESENT
THEIR STUDENTS YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS IS MAKING SURE THAT
YOU ARE READY THAT YOU ARE READY
FOR YOU KNOW MAKING A YOU KNOW
HAVING SPACE- UP FOR OUR DIVERSE
FACULTY YOU KNOW ART IS THERE
COMMUNITY RT SAT ON THOSE
CAMPUSES ARE. YOU ARE YOU THERE-
WHAT ARE THE INCENTIVES TO BE
ABLE TO HIRE FACULTY YOU KNOW OF
COLOR AND SO THESE CONVERSATIONS
ARE HAPPENING ON OUR CAMPUSES- I
THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY-
INCREDIBLE TO MEET WITH US YES
YOU MONTEREY BAY SHARED WITH ME
THEY HAVE A PILOT RIGHT NOW- OF-
HAVING A DIVERSITY ADVOCATES.
WAS AND TASTIC FOR THEIR
STEERING COMMITTEES AND- I'D
LOVE TO SEE WHAT THE RESULTS ARE
. THAT PROBE AND YOU KNOW IF WE
NEAR THE- BUT WE DO TO BE
INTENTIONAL AND WE HAVE TO BE
INTENTIONAL AND WHEN WE ARE
CREATING- FACULTY OF COLOR AND-
YOU KNOW ARE. WE MAKING SURE
THAT THAT THEY ARE BEING
WELCOMED AND- AND THAT OUR
CAMPUSES ARE READY FOR THAT.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT I WILL
NOT ASK A NOTHER QUESTION BUT I
WILL JUST- SAY THAT I APPLAUD
YOU ALL ON- WANTING TO. TAKE
PART IN THIS CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERIMENT THAT
IS MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
OFFERING A QUALITY EDUCATION. TO
ALL OF OUR FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA-
HIRING COMMITTEES WORK IF THE
HIRING COMMITTEES ARE DIVERSE-
GREAT FACULTY SEEK YOU AND WANT
TO STAY WHEN THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE WELCOME AND WHEN THEIR
CONCERNS AND ASPIRATIONS ARE
ALSO ADDRESSED. AND SOMETIMES IT
SOME PILOT PROGRAMS I'M IN
PROJECTS TO REACH OUT AND FIND
PRACTITIONERS IN THE FIELD AND
FOLKS THAT YOU WANT ON YOUR
CAMPUS BECAUSE ULTIMATELY IT'S
THE CULTURE ON CAMPUS. THAT
INVIGORATES INSPIRES- BOTH
FACULTY AND STAFF AND STUDENTS
AND THAT'S THE THING THAT MAKES
MAGIC SO I APPRECIATE YOU ALL'S
COMMITMENT TO THIS WORK AND LOOK
FORWARD TO. CONFIRMING OF
CASTING MY VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR KAMLAGER- OKAY WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC RIGHT HERE IN THE
ROOM- TWENTY TWO HUNDRED- LET ME
SEE. WHILE WE'RE DOING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER UP AGAIN- EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE ACCESS CODE. SEVEN SIX TWO
TWO FOUR SIX TWO AND THAT IS FOR
PEOPLE WHO MAY WANT TO CALL INTO
THE REMOTE TO TELECONFERENCE
NUMBER. I SEE NO ONE APPROACH IN
THE DYESS YOUR IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND
WELCOME BACK TO OUR MODERATOR TO
TEE UP THE LINES FOR PEOPLE WHO
MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OKAY IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WILL BE BACK
MOMENTARILY SO- HAVING GIVEN
THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE WILL TURN TO
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO
MISTER MODERATOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO T. FOLKS UP WHO WOULD LIKE TO
CALL IN. OPPOSITION OKAY IT IS
ONE ZERO IF YOU LIKE THIS-
PROPOSED OKAY PARDON ME THEY'RE%
IN OPPOSITION ONE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. MISTER MODERATOR
WILL TALK WITH YOU A BIT LATER
WE WILL COME BACK- TO THE DIET
SO LET ME JUST TELL YOU THAT IS
ALL A GOOD SIGN IT MEANS- FOLKS
DO NOT OPPOSE YOU AND THEY THINK
YOU'RE DOING A GOOD JOB- LET ME
SEE WHICH OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
SENATOR LAYERED GO AHEAD. I
WOULD MOVE THE CONFIRMATION OF
BOTH TRUSTEES LOPEZ AND
RODRIGUEZ. I SEE NO OBJECTION TO
THE MOTION OF TAKING UP BOTH
APPOINTEES AT THE SAME TIME SO.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROVE
KAMLAGER YES I KAMLAGER RA
LAYERED. LAYERED I BATES AYE
BATES AYE ATKINS AYE AYE THIN
SIDE ON COAL WE WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL BECAUSE A SENATOR GROVE HAD
TO STEP AWAY FOR A MOMENT BUT I
KNOW THAT SHE HAS ALREADY
EXPRESSED SHE WOULD LIKE TO BE
IN SUPPORT SO IT WILL BE ON CALL
FOR HER TO JOIN. WITH HER VOTE
TO BOTH OF YOU I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY CONGRATULATIONS WE WILL MOVE
THESE APPOINTMENTS THERE ARE
ENOUGH VOTES EVEN. I WITHOUT MS
GROVE- VOTING YET I TO MOVE THIS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR SOAKING
GRADUATIONS FROM US. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH OF AN
IMPACT. HAVE A GOOD DAY BOTH OF
YOU. WITH THAT WE WILL TAKE A
FEW MINUTES- A SHORT RECESS AND
BE BACK FOR THE FINAL
APPOINTMENT IN FIVE MINUTES
THANK YOU.
BACK TO ORDER AND I THINK GOD
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS-
WOULD BE THAT WE LIFT THE CALL
ON THE CSU TRUSTEES AND WE TOOK
THEM AS ARE. BOTH AT THE SAME
TIME SO SECRETARY WE CALL THE
ROLL. GROWTH HIGH GROVE HI FIVE
TO ZERO. THANK YOU THAT IS OUT.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL TURN TO OR
FINAL APPOINTMENT FOR TODAY
UNDER GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR THAT WOULD BE
I WHAT. YOUR CLEAR RAMSEY JD AS
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
DISABILITY ADULTS AND HOUSING
INTEGRATION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. I WANT TO SAY
WELCOME TO YOU CHIEF DEPUTY AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE PATIENCE. I AND THEN
I USED TO- INTRODUCE YOURSELF
RECOGNIZED THANK ANYONE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE MAKE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO THE SENATORS FOR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS SO WELCOME. THANK
YOU THANK YOU PRESIDENT I MEAN
MEMBERS I AM GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD UPON MY
EXPERIENCE AND EXPAND MY ABILITY
TO SERVE CALIFORNIA'S VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND WEBER. THE
MISSION OF THE PART SOCIAL
SERVICE. I APPRECIATE THE TRUST
THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM SECRETARY
KELLY AND DIRECTOR JOHNSON HAVE
BEEN ASKING ME TO SERVE IN THIS
CAPACITY. I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY HUSBAND JOHN BAKER
AND MY FATHER JIM RAMSEY WERE
VIRTUALLY ATTENDING TODAY'S
HEARING. I WANT TO THANK THEM
BOTH AS WELL AS MY CHILDREN IAN
AND CHARLOTTE MY BROTHER AND HIS
FAMILY AND MY WHOLE EXTENDED
FAMILY FOR THEIR LOVE AND
SUPPORT. I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO REMEMBER MY MOTHER KATHY. WHO
PASSED AWAY SEVERAL YEARS AGO
BUT WHO I KNOW WOULD BE PROUD. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE. SOME ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE IN MY LIFE WHO HELPED
SHAPE ME INTO WHO I AM AND WHO
HAVE SUPPORTED MY GROWTH AS A
LEADER. MY FRIENDS MY MENTORS
AND COLLEAGUES. FINALLY I'M
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE CDSS
TEAM. WERE PROVIDED ME WITH
ONGOING ASSISTANCE. EXPERTISE
AND GRACE AND WE WORK HARD EVERY
DAY TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. OVER THE LAST
FOURTEEN YEARS. I'VE WORKED TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING AT AMAZING
MISSION DRIVEN LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS. THIS ALLOWED ME
TO MAKE A COUPLE CHANGES THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
LOW INCOME OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND CHILDREN.
OTHER TAKE ON THIS NEW ROLE I'M
USING ALL THAT EXPERIENCE TO
ASSIST DIRECTOR JOHNSON IN
MEETING THE DEPARTMENT SCHOOLS
USING A PERSON CENTRED EQUITY
BASED APPROACH TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE THE
BENEFITS AND SERVICES THEY NEED.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE WHOLE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES FAMILY HELP CREATE
EQUITY ECONOMICS IN THE AND
HEALTH AND WELL BEING FOR LOW
INCOME AND VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. IT IS MY PRIVILEGE
TO BE HERE TODAY THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH I THINK
WE WILL IF YOU'RE READY SENATOR
GROVE WHICH TO START. THANK YOU
MA'AM OKAY. UPON THIS YES. THANK
YOU MISS RAMSEY FOR BEING HERE
TODAY I APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH- I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE REST OF STATE AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND WITH THE COST
INCREASES AND FOR EVER- THE
INFLATION GOING HIGHER AND
EVERYTHING AND NOT TO MAKE THIS
POLITICAL IN ANY WAY BUT- A LOT
OF OUR SENIORS ARE STRUGGLING.
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE ENDS MEET
SENT IN TO MEET AND MAKE IT
THROUGH THE MONTH. S. THE ISSUES
THAT KOBE HAD ON WITH ISOLATION
DEPRESSION AND ALL THOSE THINGS
BECAUSE A LOT OF OUR SENIORS
WERE VERY MUCH ISOLATED. SO I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
INCLUDES RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
IMPACT FOR DSS PROGRAMS- WHAT'S
THE INFORMATION. IMPLEMENTATION
TIME FOR THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THE IMPACT FOR DSS PROGRAMS.
AND THEN WHAT LEVEL OF
INVOLVEMENT DOES. AS DEPARTMENTS
SOCIAL SERVICES HAVE IN THE
CREATION OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
IN PA PRIORITIES. AND I JUST ASK
THAT BECAUSE I JUST AM LOOKING
FOR A TIMELINE AND WHEN HELP IS
GOING TO ARRIVE. YEAH I THINK
YOU CENTER GROVE I APPRECIATE
YOUR QUESTIONS AND I WAS. VERY
INVOLVED IN THE- STAKEHOLDER
CREATION OF THE MASTER PLAN
REPORT ON LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS AND MY PREVIOUS JOB AT
JUSTICE IN AGING- I WAS VERY
INVOLVED IN. ISSUES AROUND
HELPING LOW INCOME OLDER
CALIFORNIANS MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE- THE SERVICES AND BENEFITS
THEY NEED TO LIVE SAFELY IN
THEIR OWN HOMES- SO I THINK
THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS
IN WHICH THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES IS REALLY FOCUSING ON
THAT GOAL- AS YOU HEARD FROM MY
TITLE AND- FOCUSED. ON
DISABILITY ADULTS IN HOUSING
INTEGRATION AND I THINK EACH OF
THE DIVISIONS I OVERSEE. REALLY
HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN IMPROVING
THE LIVES OF OLDER ADULTS
CALIFORNIA. I'M ALL FOR SOME
EXAMPLES- WE ADMINISTER THE IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM. AND THERE WERE MULTIPLE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING GOALS THAT
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THAT ARE
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. CAN LIVE SAFELY IN
THEIR OWN HOMES. OF THAT
INCLUDES- TRAINING AND MORE-
EXCUSE ME MORE- ABILITY FOR
PEOPLE TO FEEL SUPPORTED THAT
THEIR WORK FORCES AVAILABLE FOR
THEM. AND THE DEPARTMENT RIGHT.
IN B. I. H. ASK PATH FOR. WOULD
IS A TWO HUNDRED AND NINE FIVE
GOT MILLION DOLLAR IN. THAT WAS
APPROVED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
WE'RE REALLY GOING TO FOCUS ON.
RETAINING RECRUITING AND
PROVIDING CLEAR LATTICES FOR IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROVIDERS AND WE REALLY FIND
THAT. THAT ILL BE A PATHWAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR AGES US
PROGRAM IS STRONG THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH PROVIDERS THAT ARE.
RECIPIENTS IN THE PROGRAM FEEL
WELL SUPPORTED BY THEIR
PROVIDERS AND THE PROVIDERS ARE
GIVEN- THE ABILITY TO STRENGTHEN
THEIR SKILLS AND RECEIVE THE
TRAINING WE NEED. SO THAT WILL
HELP WITH TWO DIFFERENT OF THE
MASTER PLAN SCHOOLS THE ONE ON
IMPROVING- FOR ALL AND MAKING
SURE WE HAVE A WORK FORCE THAT
CAN SUPPORT OUR INITIATIVES. I'M
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT A HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS BRANCH AT A FEW
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO HELP
SENIORS WERE STRUGGLING WITH
THEIR HOUSING. THAT INCLUDES OUR
NEW COMMUNITY EXPANSION PROGRAM
WHICH IS GOING TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF LICENSE FACILITIES
THAT SERVE OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. IT WILL ALSO HELP
TO PRESERVE EXISTING FACILITIES
AND EITHER REALLY FOCUS
PARTICULARLY ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON SSI OR S. P. OR RECEIVING
CAPPY WHO ARE SOME OF OUR LOWEST
INCOME SENIORS IN THE STATE. AND
THEN WE'RE ALSO WORKING THROUGH
OUR COMMUNICATOR LICENSING
DIVISION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE FACILITIES STATE WIDE
THAT WE NEED TO REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE WHO NEED AN
ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF CARE AND
SUPPORT ARE RECEIVING THAT. SO I
HAVE. OF WAYS IN WHICH THIS CDSS
CAN IMPACT AND IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS. AND WE'RE
VERY MUCH IN CONVERSATIONS BOTH
WITH OUR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AROUND WHAT DO
WE DO NEXT WHAT ARE THE OUR
PLANS MOVING FORWARD. AND
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
SISTER DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING WHO'S
LEADING THE MASTER PLAN EFFORTS
. AND APARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OF OUR EFFORTS ARE COORDINATED
AND THOUGHTFUL I NEVER REALLY
LIFTING UP. ON THE NEEDS OF
OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND REALLY
TAKING AN EQUITY BASED APPROACH
TO DOING THAT BECAUSE WE KNOW
NOT EVERYONE. HAS THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS THEY AGE WE
WANT TO BE PARTICULARLY MINDFUL
OF THAT AS WE PREPARE AND MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT MY NEXT
QUESTION WAS ABOUT COLLABORATION
WHICH YOU WITH OTHER AGENCIES
AND TO MAKE THAT. HAPPEN AND SO
I YOU ANSWERED THAT ON YOUR
QUESTION SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR CONFIRMATION MA'AM. THANK
YOU SOMUCH SENATORS THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE OF SENATOR LAYERED
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. A. N.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO SERVE AND INTERESTINGLY
CENTER GROVE WHAT RIGHT FOR THE
SUBJECT I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT
FOR BECAUSE THE- YOU INDICATED
IN. IN A WRITTEN STATEMENT YOU
HAD FOUR MAJOR GOALS AND
PRIORITIES IN THE FIRST ON A
CENTERING THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING IN ADDRESSING THE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS SO LET
ME BUILD ON WHAT SENATOR GROVE
JUST DID. IT AND IT'S A MORE OF.
TWO QUESTIONS ONE WE CONFIRMED
THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
AGING WE WANTED TO KNOW HOW. THE
MASTER PLAN WAS ACTUALLY GOING
TO TRANSLATE INTO ACTION HOW IS
IT ACTUALLY GOING TO BE TAKEN
BECAUSE THE FIRST THING WE DID
LAST YEAR IN THE BUDGET IS TO
CREATE POSITIONS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. WHAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS STILL OUT
THERE AND I THINK SENATOR GROVE
WAS ASKING CLEARLY ABOUT IT HOW
ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE SURE. THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY ACTIONS THAT
ARE IN FACT IMPLEMENTED OUT OF
THE MASTER PLAN FROM YOUR LEVEL
HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
HAPPENS. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION AND- AS I MENTIONED- I
WAS VERY INVOLVED IN THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WERE ABLE TO ATTEND
ANY OF THOSE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS BUT- ACTION WAS REALLY
THE WORD OF THE DAY RIGHT NOBODY
WANTED TO REPORT. OR A MASTER
PLAN THAT SAT ON THE SHELF.
THERE WAS A REAL ENERGY. AND A
SENSE OF URGENCY THAT THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING BE A CONCRETE-
JUBAL PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA AND I
AM VERY PROUD TO SAY THAT I
STAKEHOLDERS. A LOT OF REPORTS
AND THEN THE PLAN THAT THE
GOVERNOR PUT IN PLACE IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IS TRULY AN
ACTUAL PLAN AND I THINK THAT
REALLY STARTS WITH OUR FIVE FOLD
GOALS. AND REALLY HONING IN ON
WHAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE THOSE
REALITY SO AGAIN I'LL USE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS UNDER
CSS AS AN EXAMPLE. I MENTIONED-
I AGES AS A SHIP WHICH IS
GETTING OFF THE GROUND. BUT
THERE ARE MANY INITIATIVES WHICH
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF ALREADY
HELPING CALIFORNIANS- IN MANY
WAYS SO FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE A
HOUSING DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM. THAT PROGRAM'S BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR A FEW YEARS NOW
BUT WHAT WE NOW HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO AND I THINK IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE- OF THE
PRESSURE. PRESSURE FROM THE
MASTER PLAN AND THE REAL
COMMITMENT TO IT BY BOTH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE ADMINISTRATION
BUT ALSO THE LEGISLATURE. THAT
PROGRAM RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL MONEY. TO HELP US
SERVE MORE INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE STATE SO LAST FIVE YEARS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SERVE. IS
FINE HERMIT HOUSING. BUT NOW
WITH THE EXPANDED FUNDS THAT WE
RECEIVED AND THE ADDITIONAL
YEARS TO WORK ON THAT. WE ARE
BOTH GOING TO BE ABLE TO THINK
HELP CLOSER TO SIXTEEN THOUSAND
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES HELP SAYS
DISABILITY BENEFITS. AND FIND
HOUSING. BUT WE ARE ALSO ABLE TO
HELP THOSE WHO ARE NOW AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS BUT HAVEN'T
ACTUALLY FALLEN INTO
HOMELESSNESS AND WE THINK THAT
PREVENTION STRATEGY. IS GOING TO
HELP US STEM THE TIDE OF I HEARD
THIS FROM A DOCTOR WHO SHALL
WHO'S A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERT. TOLD ISSUES IN HOUSING
ISSUES. AND WHEN I THINK SHE
MADE REALLY CLEAR WAS. WE BOTH
HAVE TO HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
THE MOST CRISIS RIGHT NOW LIVING
ON THE STREETS BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO CLOSE THE DOOR HOME. I THINK
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT AND LARGE
AGENCY AND THE ADMINISTRATION
MORE GENERALLY IS TRYING TO DO
IS TO TAKE A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH BOTH HELP THE MOST
NEEDY RIGHT NOW. BUT ALSO TO
THINK ABOUT THE PROACTIVE
STRATEGIES WE CAN TAKE TO CLOSE
THE FRONT DOOR. SO I THINK YOU
KNOW THERE'S THE- AGE PROGRAM
WHICH IS. ALSO HOUSE.
UNCONNECTED IN. A PROTECT
SERVICES THAT ALREADY BY BUT
ALSO WAS. SIGNIFICAN ADDITIONAL
FUNDS. BOTH OF THOSE PROGRAMS
HAVE NOW EXPANDED INTO. A ONE
INCH OF FIFTY SEVEN COUNTIES AND
TO TRIBAL ENTITIES AND THE OTHER
ONE TO FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES SO
WITHOUT. ALMOST COMPLETELY
COVERING THE WHOLE STATE WITH
THOSE PROGRAMS. AND THEN AS WE
ROLL OUT OUR COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM. GOING TO AS I
MENTIONED BUILD CAPACITY WITHIN
OUR SYSTEM WHICH IS NEW FOR US
AND I THINK AGAIN IT'S GOING TO
BE A REAL TANGIBLE RESULTS. AT
THE END OF THE NEXT FEW YEARS
WILL HAVE PHYSICALLY MORE
LICENSE FACILITIES FOR OLDER
ADULTS TO LIVE SAFELY AND SO I
THINK. HOW I SEE THE MASTER PLAN
IS A LIVING DOCUMENT AS A
FRAMEWORK WE'RE GOING TO FIND
NEW SOLUTIONS NEW IDEAS NEW
PROBLEMS WILL EMERGE AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO USE THE
PRINCIPLES AND THE GOALS OF THE
MASTER PLAN TO DRIVE US. TOWARD
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. WELL MY
PRECIADO SAID I THINK. THE
CHALLENGES A NEW RACE TO
QUESTION AND SORT OF YOUR ANSWER
THE CHALLENGES. IS MAKING SURE
THAT. IT'S NOT JUST HAVING GOALS
AND- ACHIEVING NUMBERS IT'S
WORKING ON THE GROUND TO MAKE
SURE IT'S REALLY IMPACTING
CHANGE IN IT IT'S LIKE I KNOW
BEING ANSWER. HAVING BEEN IN
CERTAIN ADMINISTRATIVE POSITIONS
MY QUESTION IS ALWAYS. ARE WE
GOING TO GET TO THE END AND HOW
ARE PEOPLE GOING TO REALLY FEEL
THE HIM. FROM WHAT IT IS WORTH
IT AND I THINK. THAT HAS TO BE
THE UNDERLYING QUESTION AND- AND
WHEN YOU WENT INTO HOMELESSNESS.
THAT'S AN ISSUE. THAT'S WHERE
YOU RAISED THE NEXT QUESTION
BECAUSE I THINK THAT ARE HIDDEN
MY DISTRICT. IT IS JUST OFF THE
CHARTS AND WHAT THE IMPACTS ARE
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING OBVIOUSLY
WERE IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO
THAT'S- THAT'S TRUE TOO AND I
KNOW MAYBE YOU HALF. OUR OUR ONE
SUBSET OF D. DEALING WITH AGING
AND- WITH THAT PART. THE REAL
CHALLENGE IS MAKE IT TO THAT OP
DE. IS MAKING SURE WHAT COMES
FROM SACRAMENTO SUPPORTS WHAT'S
WORKING ON THE GROUND AND
SOMETIMES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE
SACRAMENTAL. THERE IS A
DISCONNECT AND I THINK PEOPLE
WOULD. IN THIS AND OTHER
COMMITTEES ARE PROBABLY GETTING
TIRED OF ME TALKING ABOUT. THAT
THE PARK HOMELESS IN MY HOME
TOWN IS BIGGER ON A PER CAPITA
BASIS SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES
AND SAN DIEGO AND OAKLAND. BUT
THE MONEY COMES ON A PER CAPITA
BASIS SO IT NEVER ALLOWS THEM TO
GET AHEAD. MARCUSE A PER CAPITA
BASIS ON THE GENERAL POPULATION
THAT NUMBER ALLOWS THEM TO GET
AHEAD. OF WHAT THE ISSUE IS TO
HAVE SUCH A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
THERE'S CERTAIN PLACES WHERE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN DONE. THAT
REALLY WORK AND THAT PEOPLE ARE
STEPPING UP AND DOING THINGS TO
GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREET AND
WAS SERVICES AND YET AT THE SAME
TIME. THE MONEY COMES IN CERTAIN
PARTS IT DOESN'T COME. FROM HERE
AUTOMATICALLY OR AND ARE EASILY
READILY EASIER WE WAY. TO GET TO
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING THAT
ON THE GROUND THAT SO THAT'S
WHAT I WAS LOOKING FOR. IN A
QUESTION WITH REGARD TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS THE FACT
THAT YOU SORT OF RECOGNIZE. TO
THE OUT. SURE EVERYTHING IS
GUIDE TO THE OUTCOMES I THINK
THAT'S REALLY TRUE WITH
HOMELESSNESS AS WELL AND AFTER
MY WILL RIFF OR RENT- GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO MAYBE TALK ABOUT THAT
BEFORE WE MOVE THANK YOU I'M
GLAD YOU- YOU YOU PROVIDE ME A
LITTLE MORE CHANCE TO ANSWER
BECAUSE ONE OF THINGS I REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR IS
HOW COMMITTED THE DEPARTMENT IS
AND HOW COMMITTED I AM. TO
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
HAVING THE TYPE OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WITH OUR COUNTIES
WITH OUR- RECIPIENTS WHO ARE
HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE EITHER
WITH HOMELESSNESS OR RECEIVING
AS A SIRE I JUST US WHO ARE THE
PROVIDERS OF THESE SERVICES YOU
KNOW REALLY TALKING TO THE
SPECTRUM OF GOAL- AND MEETING
PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE SO THAT
MEANS LISTEN TO THEM IN THE
LANGUAGES THEY SPEAK COMING INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES SEEING WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND AND
REALLY HEARING THE FEEDBACK AND
BEING BOTH WILLING TO BE. I
THINK BOTH REALLY BROAD MINDED
AND WHAT HEARING WHAT ARE WE
DOING THAT WORKS WHAT ARE WE
DOING THAT- NEED TO PROVE MEANT
AND REALLY TAKING THAT. FEEDBACK
AND THEN GOING BACK. IN THIS
CONVERSATION AND WE THINKING HOW
WE IMPROVE. OUR PROGRAMS. I'M
HERE PLEASE I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO DO THOUGHTFULLY- AROUND
HOMELESSNESS IS. THE THOUGHTFUL
IN OUR ALLOCATIONS. AND TRYING
TO MAKE THE MONEY FLOW AS-
SEAMLESSLY AND SIMPLY AS WE CAN
WALL. PROTECTING GOVERNMENT
FUNDS AND MAKING SURE. THAT THE
MONEY IS GOING WHO NEEDS IT. SO
FOR EXAMPLE WE ARE WORKING
CURRENTLY ON RELEASING A NOTICE
OF FUNDING ALLOCATION. AS PART
OF OUR COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM. WILL HELP PRESERVE OUR
FACILITIES AND HELP ALLOW FOR
OPERATING SUBSIDIES FOR LICENSED
FACILITIES. THAT MONEY IS GOING
TO GO THROUGH COUNTIES. BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT IS WHEN WE
ALLOCATE THAT MONEY REALLY NOT
JUST SIMPLY WHO'S THE BIGGEST
COUNTY YOU GET THE MOST MONEY
BUT LOOKING AT. WHAT IS YOUR S.
ASIDE POPULATION WITHIN THE
COUNTY WHAT IS YOUR HOMELESSNESS
COUNT WITHIN THE COUNTY AND HOW
MANY LICENSED FACILITIES DO YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THAT COUNTY.
SO IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF HOW WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO TAKE A
THOUGHTFUL LOOK AT THE FACTORS
YOU'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT. AND
NOT SIMPLY JUST BEING NARROW
MINDED ABOUT OUR FOCUS STAY ON
UP FOR STATISTICS BUT REALLY.
KNOWING THAT THE WORK WE DO
IMPACTS PEOPLE'S LIVES AND WE
REALLY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE PEOPLE'S LIVES BUT WE
CAN'T DO THAT IF WE'RE NOT
LISTENING TO PEOPLE IF WE'RE NOT
GETTING THE MONEY OUT
APPROPRIATELY. AND IF WE'RE NOT
A LEARNING FROM WHAT WE'RE
DOING- WE ARE VERY MUCH IF
YOU'VE GOT A POSITIVE FEEDBACK
LOOP RIGHT NOW AROUND OUR
PROGRAMS WE REACH OUT OFTEN
STAKEHOLDERS WE LET. THEM REVIEW
OUR GUIDANCE BEFORE IT'S- AT
LEAST WE TAKE COMMENTS RESPOND
FEEDBACK. ALWAYS HAPPY MEET WITH
AND HEAR HOW THINGS ARE WORKING.
AND WE'RE ALWAYS WILLING TO HEAR
WHERE MAYBE OUR PROGRAMS- ARE
THERE ARE GAPS IN WHERE THERE
ARE. MORE AND MORE THINGS ARE
NEEDED AND ONE THING I JUST DID
WANT TO CLARIFY BECAUSE-
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF THE WORK I'VE
DONE IS AROUND OLDER ADULTS BUT
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT OUR
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. COVER A BRIGHTER.
COLORS TRUMP. AND ALSO SERVED-
FAMILIES ON CAL WORKS- FAMILIES
INVOLVED IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OLDER ADULTS
THE WHOLE SPECTRUM OF AGES- YOU
KNOW. TWENTY TWO. TWO HUNDRED
YEAH A PLUS SO. WE REALLY ARE
TRYING TO THINK ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR
PROGRAMS ARE SERVING WORKING FOR
PEOPLE. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE COMPREHENSIVE ANSWER AND I
ACTUALLY LOOK FORWARD. TO
WORKING. WITH YOU ON THIS GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU SENATOR. AND
DESIST THIS CONVERSATION IS JUST
THE START THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE A DETAILED RESPONSE.
THANK YOU EARLIER. MUCH. OF
MANIFIESTO. COOL THANK YOU-
DIRECTOR RAMSEY FOR THAT VERY
COMPREHENSIVE ANSWERS TO THE
QUESTIONS. OF MY COLLEAGUES
BEFORE ME BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
ESPECIALLY SENATOR LARRY YOU
COVER THE ISSUES THAT ARE ON
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A- MAJOR
CONCERN ON THE LAST THE
INTERVIEW WE HAD. WE CLEAR THAT-THE CONTINUE OF CARE ISSUE WAS A
SIGNIFICAN IN MY FAMILY I AND MY
BROTHER WAS VERY ILL AND TRYING
TO FIND A PLACE IN HIS. OF HIS
FUNDS RAN OUT TO WAS GOING TO BE
A REAL CHALLENGE ON MY PART OF.
THE COUNTRY AND I IN ORANGE
COUNTY IN PARTICULAR SO THAT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THAT IS UP AND
RUNNING AND THERE'S A LOT OF
EFFORT BEING FOCUSED ON THAT
THAT'S WONDERFUL- I HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TEMPORARY PROJECT GREEN KEY
FUNDING. ISSUE AND WOOD EXPIRES
DO WE HAVE A PLAN FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE RECEIVING CARE
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF DEBATE
ABOUT THE HOUSING FIRST- YOU
KNOW THE ISSUE WHERE NO
TREATMENT YES- KINDA. PUT
SOMEONE AT HOME BUT DON'T GET
PLAN TO THOSE WHO ARE. SUFFERING
FROM. AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE BEST ON.
MANNER AND TAKING CARE AND
HOPING THAT WE GET TAKING CARE
OF THEM AND HOPING THAT WE GET
THEM BACK HI INTO SOBRIETY ANDY
AND TO- YOU KNOW A POSITIVE
PLACE IN OUR COMMUNITIES HE
DIDN'T MENTION THAT SPECIFICALLY
NOT SURE THAT THAT- YEAR REACHES
THERE WITH THE HOME KEEP.
PROJECT THE ROOM KEY PROJECT
EXCUSE ME SO IF YOU HAVE A
LITTLE MAYBE A LITTLE IN WHITE
MEN ON ON IF THERE'S ANY LOOK
SEE AT THAT AND WHAT WE ARE
DOING- AND ALL WE'VE HEARD LIMIT
LET ME SAY THIS WE'VE HEARD FROM
OUR COUNTY IS THAT. THERE IS A
MINOR PROBLEM AT THE MOMENT AND
I SAY MINOR I DON'T KNOW WITHOUT
REALLY ENTAILS IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE- LEAVING ROOM KEY
AND THEN BACK ON THE STREET I
DON'T KNOW BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE COUNT YET. HOUSE SIGNIFICANT
IDEAS BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WILL CERTAINLY COME INTO YOUR
YOUR ARENA AT SOME POINT IN TIME
IF NOT ALREADY AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY THOUGHT FOUND OUT ABOUT WHAT
WITH THE TRANSITION AND HOW ARE
WE HELPING OUR COUNTIES WITHOUT
ISSUE. YEAH THANK YOU. UP
PROJECT ROOM. UNDER MY PURVIEW.
OF AND THERE ARE FEW THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING- TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION I THINK FIRST. OF ALL
WITH REGARD TO THE FUNDING WE
ARE DOING I THOUGHT THE WIND
DOWN OF PROJECT ROOM SHE- OF THE
PROJECT WHICH IS HAS BEEN A
HISTORIC FIRST IN THE NATION-
PROGRAM. HAS SERVED MORE THAN
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP. ONE OF
THE THINGS THE PROJECT ROOM HE
WAS REALLY SET UP. TO DO- WHAT.
TIMES TEMPORARY WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE HIGH RISK OF KOBE OR WERE
ACTUALLY EXPERIENCING- COULD
INFECTIONS AND NEEDED TO HAVE A
PLACE TO ISOLATE ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY WERE LIVING ON THE STREET.
SO OUR INTENTIONS FROM THE START
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE TO PROVIDE
PEOPLE A SAFE PLACE- AND TO GET
AS MANY SERVICES INVOLVED WITH
PEOPLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY-
WERE ABLE TO IF POSSIBLE EXITED
TO. PERMANENT HOUSING OR TO
ANOTHER STATE PLACE. NOT
EVERYONE. HAS PROGRESSED INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING- AND SOME OF
THOSE PEOPLE WERE AT VERY SHORT
TERM TEMPORARY STAYS BIG. BUTTON
TIONS. WORKING CLOSELY WITH H.
CITY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
CONNECTING OR PROJECT ROOM HE
WITH THEIR PROJECT HOME HE- TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE DO HAVE A
PATHWAY. WE ARE TRYING TO THINK
AGAIN ABOUT HOW THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE AND HELP OUR LICENSE.
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES PROCREATE
PLACEMENTS FOR SOME- INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE EXITING HOMELESSNESS. WE
DO HAVE A GROWING NUMBER OF
OLDER ADULTS WHO ARE HOMELESS
AND- THEY MIGHT NEED A NEW AND
LOCAL. AND WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO
REALLY LOOK AT OUR OTHER
PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR- OWN PURVIEW
AT SOCIAL SERVICES BUT ALSO WITH
IN- WHAT OTHER AGENCIES ARE
OFFERING AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE REALLY HAVING A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH. THAT'S
BEING VERY MUCH FACILITATED
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS WHICH- THE
DEPARTMENT IS A MEMBER AND
REALLY WE THINK IS GIVING US A
LOTOF OPPORTUNITIES. AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE'RE REALLY
FINDING THAT- YOU KNOW HOUSING
PEOPLE FIRST WHAT IT GIVES THEM
IT'S- THE SAFETY AND ABILITY TO
FOCUS ON THE OTHER PIECES THAT
THEY MAY NEED HELP WITH. SO FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S MAYBE STRUGGLING
WITH A MEDICAL CONDITION THAT'S
LIKE A DIET DIABETES I AM
CONTROLLED IT'S VERY HARD TO GET
TROLL ON THE STREET. BUT WHEN
THEY HAVE HOUSING S. WELL HAVE
SOME STABILITY IN A LIFE THEIR
MUCH MORE ABLE TO MANAGE THEIR
MEDICAL CONDITION. AS WE
TRANSPORTED SUBSTANCE USE MORE
AS A MEDICAL CONDITION THAT
NEEDS THAT SORT OF STABILITY AND
CONSTANT CARE WE THINK WE'RE
GOING TO SIMILARLY SEE THOSE
KIND OF RESULTS WERE REALLY
GIVING PEOPLE. A TRUE
OPPORTUNITY. TO FIND. FIND AND
BEING- WITH OUR HOUSING POLICIES
. WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT IS NOW
GONE I'D LIKE TO BE ON YEARS OF
CALLED BACKLESS FOR YEARS CATCH
ME UP LEFT A BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE ARE THAT I
WANT TO FOLLOW SO I'LL BE
CONNECTING BACK WITH YOU YOU CAN
KEEP ME UPDATED ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE HOMELESS COUNCIL FINALLY
COME IN AND WE TAKE A DEEPER
LOOK AT. YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT OF
WHAT'S WORKING I GUESS WE'D SAY
WHAT BEST PRACTICES ARE IN I
WILL CONTINUE TO I GUESS FROM GO
BACK TO THE DISCUSSION OF
HOUSING FIRST BECAUSE I BELIEVE
WE NEED HOUSING FIRST CLASS
WHERE PEOPLE ARE PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TREATMENT. AS
PUTTING IN A FARM HOUSE AND NOT
PROVIDING OUR INSTANT REFERRALS
TO COMMUNITY SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE VERY DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE THAT I TELL YOU THAT
JUST BECAUSE I WAS A SOCIAL
WORKER ONCE UPON A TIME TO HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR ADULT DAY
THAN DOING THAT VERY THING. AND
IT'S VERY IT'S A LOT EASIER WHEN
SOMEONE HEALTH UP THEIR
FINGERTIPS AND THESE WOULD BE
VOLUNTARY OUR HOUSING FIRST PLUS
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY DO HAVE
PRESCRIBED OF REQUIREMENTS FOR
CERTAIN TREATMENTS SO I THINK AT
SOME POINT TIME WE MIGHT ALL GET
THERE BUT I KNOW RIGHT NOW IT'S
THE IT'S AN EARLY CONCEPT. FOR
ONLY ABOUT PRE WILL IMPRESS AND
ALL OF THAT I THINK WE COULD
WORK THROUGH THE BUT I'D I'D YOU
TO KEEP ME UP TO DATE AND ARE
YOU CERTAINLY WILL HAVE MY
STRONG SUPPORT GOT A BIG JOB BUT
YOU SEEM VERY WELL QUALIFIED TO
BE ABLE TO HANDLE. THIS ALONG
THAT PATH TO SUCCESS. OF FINALLY
ELIMINATING ALL THESE VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEMS WE HAVE. IN OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION THANK YOU
AND YOU'LL HAVE MY VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES AND I WILL
DEFINITELY FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
AROUND THESE ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES ARE
SENATOR COME LONGER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM UM AN DIE- IT'S
BEEN GREAT LISTENING TO YOUR
RESPONSES I AGREE WITH SENATOR
LAYERED THEY ARE INCREDIBLY
COMPREHENSIVE AND THOUGHTFUL SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT BECAUSE I
ASSUME THAT YOU CARRY THAT WITH
YOU- IN THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING- ON A DAILY BASIS THAT
KIND OF- THOUGHTFULNESS HI I
HAVE A QUESTION I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- SS I SS P.
RECIPIENTS AND I HSS PROGRAM.
DON'T YOU LOVE ALL THE ACRONYMS
WE KNOW THAT- THERE'S BEEN A
DROP IN THE NUMBER OF RECIPIENTS
THAT ARE IN FACILITIES- WE ALSO
KNOW THAT- I GUESS 43% OF
FACILITIES ARE EXCEPT READ. WITH
SERIOUS ILLNESSES- OR WHO HAVE
SS I SS P. OR BOTH AND- WE ALSO
KNOW THAT SIXTEEN OF THOSE
FACILITIES CLOSED PERMANENTLY IN
THE FIRST HALF OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE LOAN SO THAT'S A LOSS OF A
NUMBER OF- BEDS. NOT UNDER YOUR
PURVIEW I KNOW BUT- THERE'S ALSO
SOME CHALLENGES WE HAVE UP WITH
OUR NURSING HOME FACILITIES- AND
MAJOR DEFICIENCIES- THAT ARE IN
SOME OF THEM YOU KNOW HUGE
FEDERAL FINES- LEVIED ON SOME OF
THEM AND REALLY FEAR AMONG THOSE
FOLKS THAT ARE LIVING IN THEM.
ULTIMATELY MY QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW DO WE SUPPORT SENIORS WHO
ARE LOOKING TO YOUR DEPARTMENT-
FOR SAFE CHOICES- AS IT RELATES
TO THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE OFFERED
BY THE STATE AND SO JUST WANTED
TO HEAR FROM YOU- IN YOUR
ASSESSMENT WHAT DO YOU THINK ARE
THE THREE BIGGEST CHALLENGES.
THAT THE I STOP APPROACH. THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE LIVING ON THE MARGINS
AND MAY FEEL LIKE THEY EITHER
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF CHOICES
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE MANY GOOD
CHOICES WERE THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW HOW TO ACCESS- INFORMATION
ON THE GOOD CHOICES THAT WE WANT
TO PROVIDE THEM. THANK YOU
SENATOR CALL LONGER LET ME JUST
MAKE SURE THAT I'M UNDERSTANDING
YOUR TWO PARTS YOUR QUESTION
I'LL I'LL TALK TO FIRST TO THE
SSI RECIPIENTS IN THE
FACILITIES. WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
SOME CLOSURES- AND THEN I'LL
TALK ABOUT THE THREE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE SEEING AN
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES MY
UNDERSTANDING YOUR CHANCES. YEAH
GREAT. THANK YOU- SO. AS BE
RECIPIENTS FOR TAKING THIS HE'S-
VERY SERIOUSLY AND DOING A LOT
TO THINK ABOUT. HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT OUR LOWEST INCOME
CALIFORNIANS IT AND
THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS
FOR DOING THAT SO WITHIN OUR-
COMMUNICATOR LICENSING DIVISION.
WHO LICENSES THOSE FACILITIES I
THINK PART OF IT HERE- TO WHAT
YOU JUST REPRESENTED WAS WHAT
REALLY STARTING WITH DATA RIGHT
WHAT DO WE- KNOW. WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THESE FACILITIES
HOW ARE THEY FARING AND WHAT ARE
THE- CHALLENGES THEY'RE FACING
AND WE KNOW THAT- SSI
STAYING
COULD YOU KNOW THE YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD THIS WHEN THE DIRECTOR
REGION WAS TALKING. YOU KNOW THE
COMPLEXITY OF OUR SENIORS- AND
THEIR NEEDS JUST IS CHANGING. SO
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WERE
WORKING VERY DELIBERATELY IS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT. THE DATA TELLS
US ABOUT THE FACILITIES. AND
WHERE THEY NEED SUPPORT. AND
THEN WE MAKING SURE THE OUR
LIFE. IS PROVIDING THAT YOU KNOW
SHE A- MAKING SURE WE WEAPON ARE
MAKING WE'RE DOING THE OUTRAGE.
AND- MAKING FACILITIES ARE SAFE
RIGHTS REALLY ABOUT HER.
COMPLIANCE FORCED STRATEGY THAT
WE OUT FOR PROMISED. ON BUT WE
KNOW THAT. LICENSING ALONE
CANNOT SOURCE THAT. BECAUSE IT'S
NOT. BUILT.
TO MAKE THIS A SUCCESSFUL
ENDEAVOR. THAT COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION IS DOING TWO MAJOR
THINGS IT'S REALLY GOING TO FUND
EXPANSION OF FACILITIES WE'RE
HOPING RIGHT NOW ARE EARLY
ESTIMATES WERE HOPING TO HAVE AS
MANY AS FOUR THOUSAND NEW GUIDES
THAT ARE SERVING AS A SITE
RECIPIENTS AND PART OF GETTING
THAT MONEY. IS MAKING. A
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO ALL
THOSE BAGS TO SSI RECIPIENTS SO
THAT WERE REALLY- CREATING A
MORE GUARANTEED CAPACITY WITHIN
OUR CITY- BUT SOME OF THAT MONEY
IS ALSO GOING TO PRESERVING
EXISTING. AND YOU MAY BE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE FIFTY FIVE
MILLION THAT THE LEGISLATURE WAS
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
INVESTING IN OPERATING
SUBSIDIES. TO HELP OUR CURRENT
FACILITIES MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN MEET THEIR OPERATING COSTS
WHETHER THAT STAMPING UTILITIES
ON SORT OF ALL THE OTHER NON
SERVICE RELATED. EXPENSES THAT
GO ALONG WITH RUNNING THE
FACILITY. BUT THEY'RE REALLY
SUPPORTED AND THEN WE ALSO
ADDITIONAL MONEY TO PER SERVICE
SO IT IS THAT MAYBE HAVING LIKE
PHYSICAL PLANT. IN FLIGHT. WE
CAN THE- OF. YOU KNOW I NEED FOR
A NEW- FURNACE OR AIR
CONDITIONER WE'RE DOING- THAT
KIND OF REHABILITATION WORK AS
WELL AND WE'RE HOPING. THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE SOME OF THE
PRESSURE OFF THESE EXISTING
FACILITIES IN TERMS OF THEIR-
FINANCES SO THAT THEY CAN REALLY
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE GOOD
SERVICES TO OUR- RECIPIENTS- ON.
THAT PROGRAM IS REALLY YOU KNOW
IS MOVING ALONG WE ARE ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS NOW WE'RE HOPING TO
START MAKING OUR FIRST AWARDS
THIS SUMMER. AND WE'RE HOPING
WITHIN THE NEXT FOUR TO SIX
WEEKS TO BE RELEASING OUR NOTICE
OF FUNDING ALLOCATIONS. FOR
THOSE PRESERVATION PLANS SO
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO GO FULL
STEAM AHEAD- AND REALLY TAKE
THIS CAPACITY ISSUE VERY
SERIOUSLY- CAN OVER. THE I JUST
AS POPULATION- YOU KNOW THIS IS
A VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART
ALL THE WORK I DO IS NEAR AND
DEAR TO MY HEART BUT I'VE WORKED
ON I JUST LAST FOR A LONG TIME
AND YOU KNOW IT'S JUST. HONESTLY
A GREAT PROGRAM I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE ALWAYS STOP AND REALIZE
WHAT A UNIQUE PROGRAM IT IS
NATIONWIDE- IT REALLY ALLOWS
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ON MEDICARE
ALL IN OUR LOW INCOME TO LIVE
SAFELY IN THEIR OWN HOMES AND
HIGHER. THEIR OWN PROVIDERS. SO
IT'S REALLY- IT'S REALLY
ENABLING BOTH- YOU KNOW
INDEPENDENCE FOR OUR OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. IT'S MAKING SURE
THAT OUR SUPPORT OF SERVICES ARE
REALLY REACHING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND- SO. YOU KNOW THERE'S
SO MUCH BETTER ABOUT IT ON THERE
ARE CHALLENGES TO THE PROGRAM I
THINK. THE THREE BIGGEST I WOULD
SAY IS NUMBER ONE RETAINING AND
RECRUITING WORKFORCE. I'M YOU
KNOW I THINK WORKFORCE IS
PROBABLY COME UP IN EVERY
CONVERSATION ABOUT EVERY TOPIC
YOU KNOW WE JUST ARE IN A PLACE
WHERE WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE SUPPORTING OUR
WORKFORCE- EIGHT HUNDRED
PATHWAYS PROGRAM THAT I SPOKE
ABOUT EARLIER IS REALLY- WORKING
TO DO THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL TRAINING
AND SUPPORT FOR OUR I JUST AS
PROVIDERS THAT'S GOING TO
INCLUDE PAYING THEM FOR THEIR
TRAINING HOURS. IT'S GOING TO
INCLUDE IN. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE RETAINING PROVIDERS. AND
THEN IT'S ALSO GOING TO PROVIDE
COACHING SUPPORT TO PROVIDE
CAREER LATTICES FOR PEOPLE. SO I
THINK WORKFORCE TO ME IT'S JUST
ABSOLUTE TOP OF THE LIST. ON
NEXT I THINK OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGE IS MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE. LISTENING AND RESPONDING TO
OUR STAKEHOLDERS IN THE I JUST
AS- I'M SPACE I THINK. THAT WHAT
WE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR DURING
THE PANDEMIC WAS THE NEED FOR AN
INTERACTIVE SYSTEM- WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING TO IMPLEMENT
THAT. WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING-
FINALIZE THAT WE HAVE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE OUT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING EXTENSIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. TO REALLY FIND- THE
PATH FORWARD ON A PERMANENT DACA
SYSTEM SO THAT IF SOMEONE HAS
SOMEONE YOU KNOW A PROVIDER. WHO
CAN'T COME AND THEY NEED THE
SERVICES THAT THERE'S TO PROVIDE
SERVICE. AND THEN I THINK THREE
IT'S SOMETHING BE THOUGHT ABOUT.
AROUND GROWTH OF THE PROGRAM-
YOU KNOW. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THIS PROGRAM IS HERE AND
AVAILABLE FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT AND SO WE'RE JUST BEING
REALLY. MAKE SURE WERE OPERATING
THE PROGRAM- EFFICIENTLY. AND
EFFECTIVELY AND REALLY WITH OUR
CAL PARTNER. FOR DOING THE ON
THE GO. IMPLEMENTATION JUST MAKE
SURE. WERE SERVING- THE PEOPLE
WHO NEED TO BE SERVED AND MAKING
SURE BEING- THOUGHTFUL- YOU KNOW
STEWARDS OF A GOVERNMENT FUNDS.
FOR
I JUST TO CONFIRM THAT THEY HAVE
. LIKE ANNUAL. IN TRIAL CARE
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED TO BE ABLE.
TO SEE THE BEST. WERE OFTEN. GO
IN AND HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE- AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE
GETTING SUPPORT. THEY NEED.
SAFETY FOR CHILDREN AND THAT OUR
LICENSING ANALYSTS ARE ABLE TO
GET YOU DISABILITIES. YEARLY NOW
AND REALLY- HAVE EYES ON THE
FACILITIES AND REALLY BE ABLE TO
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON AND FEEL
THAT WERE. COMFORTABLE AND
CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE- PROVIDING
THE BEST SERVICES WE CAN FOR OUR
CHILDREN YES SOME TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT SINCE YOU MENTIONED-
TUCKER LAWCENTER MAY HAVE A
SHOT. AND HE'S ALL. AND THE-
GOAL OF FEMALE WARRIORS IN THE
FIGHT FOR CHILD CARE SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR CALL LONGER AND I JUST
OF CNC STROLL WAS. FIRST IS A
LAWYER. HE SHE GOT ME GOING TO
MY CREW. IS A SMALLER WORLD
TONIGHT WE- AND WE ARE ONE OF
THE WE ARE THE LARGEST STATE SO.
HI IT'S GREAT TO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE SO MANY INCREDIBLE
RESOURCES HERE CALIFORNIANS- A
LOT OF GROUND HAS BEEN COVERED
ON SOME REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUES
FOR MY COLLEAGUES I JUST WANTED
TO. ASK ONE- DIFFERENT UPDATE- I
KNOW THAT COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING IS THE LARGEST
DIVISION ON UNDER YOU. AND I
WANTED TO JUST ASK WHERE WE ARE
IN A STATUS MYBE UPDATE OF. THE
FACILITIES- THAT WERE
DECERTIFIED THE OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES FOR THE PLACEMENT OF
FOSTER YOUTH. I KNOW THAT OF ALL
WILL SPEND ALMOST A COUPLE YEARS
NOW OR AT LEAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AGO. ALL HUNDRED THIRTY YOUTH
WERE BROUGHT BACK THAT HAVE BEEN
PLACED IN OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES SO. I WANTED TO KIND
OF GET A SENSE FROM YOU HOW- OUR
THE FOSTER YOUTH WITH THE
HIGHEST NEEDS BEING CARED FOR
WITHOUT THIS OPTION DO WE HAVE.
AT THIS POINT SUFFICIENT
CAPACITY CAN YOU JUST GIVE ME A
GENERAL UPDATE ON ON HOW THAT'S
GOING. YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS AND I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
THERE'S SORT OF TWO DIVISIONS
OVERSEEING THIS WORK- OBVIOUSLY
COMMUNICATOR LICENSING IS A BIG
PIECE OF THIS BECAUSE WE LICENSE
OUR CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES. BUT OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES WHICH IS UNDER
THE PURVIEW OF MY COLLEAGUE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR TRAIL. UP IS YOU
KNOW OVERSEEING THE WELFARE
SYSTEM SO WE'RE REALLY WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS ISSUE- AND I'LL
JUST SPEAK UP MOSTLY FROM MY
SIDE AS A LIGHT. PASSING I'M
SORRY I SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLEARER
ABOUT THE CAPACITY ISSUE. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
AND SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN DOING A
LOT OF WORK ON GETTING A LOT OF
THOUGHT TO I JUST WANT TO SAY
FIRST. OF WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO A TEMPORARY- YOU
KNOW SORT OF A STEP DOWN FROM OR
OUT OF STATE FACILITIES WE
BROUGHT ALL THE U. FAQ THERE IS
A CURRENT PROCESS IN PLACE WHERE
IF THERE'S A CHILD SPECIFIC NEED
FOR AN OUT OF STATE FACILITY. A
COUNTY CAN APPLY FOR THAT. NOT
HAD ANY COUNTY'S ACTIVATE THAT-
THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT CHOICE
AND SO WE DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
ANY CHILDREN PLACE OUT OF STATE.
I'M NOT LEASES TO REALLY LOOK AT
WHAT ARE IN STATE- CAPACITY AND
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR OUR USE-
ON. THAT IS A COMPLICATED
QUESTION I DO WANT TO BE HONEST
BECAUSE WHAT THE CAPACITY NEEDS
ARE ARE GOING TO BE SPECIFIC BY
COUNTY. BUT ALSO SPECIFIC BY THE
MIX OF CHILDREN WHO WERE IN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM AT ANY GIVEN TIME
NOT COUNTY. SO WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS THERE IS BOTH THE
NEED TO HAVE BROADER SYSTEMIC
CONVERSATIONS AND REALLY TO LOOK
AT THE FACILITIES WE LICENSE
RIGHT NOW DO WE HAVE THE RIGHT.
BASILIDES LIES. ARE WE CONTINUE
TO WORK TOWARD GOALS TO HOME
LIKE SETTINGS AND WE WILL FROM
HOME SO. AND YOU HAVE SOARED
INNOVATIVE OPTIONS THAT PEOPLE
CAN USE WHEN WE HAVE MORE
COMPLEX CARE IS ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE EXPLORING. A WITH
COUNTIES IS THE SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
WHICH ALREADY DISPOSED STR
TEEPEES THAT ALREADY EXIST. CAN
WE SOMETIMES USE THEM AS ONLY
ACCOUNT OF ONE OR TWO THAT
REALLY ARE WAITING AND READY FOR
KIDS WHO ARE HAVING. SEX NEEDS
TO A REALLY TRAUMA INFORMED AND
READY READY TO WORK WITH OUR
CHILDREN- SO THAT'S A
CONVERSATION HAVING US. LEVEL
WHAT'S AVAILABLE AND THEN WE'RE
HAVING A LOT OF IN DEPTH
CONVERSATIONS WITH COUNTIES WHEN
THEY EITHER WE'VE SEEN THAT
THEY- NEEDED US TO REACH OUT TO
THEM OR WITH MADE AFFIRMATIVELY
REACHED OUT TO US. TO REALLY SEE
WHAT IS THE MIX OF FACILITIES
YOU HAVE. WHAT IS THE CHILDREN'S
NEEDS RIGHT NOW WHERE. THERE ARE
GAPS IN THAT- CONTINUE ON RIGHT
NOW- FOR SOME CHINESE- YOU KNOW
THEY ARE STRUGGLING. ONE OF
THINGS WE ARE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IS WHETHER-
FOR VIEW COUNTIES THEY WILL NEED
A TRANSITIONAL. SHELTER FACILITY
TO BE LICENSED AND THOSE WOULD
BE REALLY- WE HAVE HAD A-
QUESTIONS FROM A FEW COUNTIES.
TO THOSE UP AND WHAT DOES REALLY
DO IS PUT GIVE THE COUNTY SOME
SPACE AND TIME TO HELP THEM
CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT THEIR
LARGER CAPACITY. AND THE
PERMANENT CAPACITY WALL THE
TRANSITIONAL SHELTERS GIVING
THEM. AN EXTRA A TOOL IN YOUR
TOOL BELT AROUND. UNSAFELY
HOUSING CHILDREN WHO ARE IN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM. SO WE KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION AND
WORK TO CONTINUE TO DO BUT WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO DO IT IN
PARTNERSHIP- IN THE DIVISION
EXCUSE ME IN THE DEPARTMENT
BETWEEN DIVISIONS. AND WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS AND OUR
STAKEHOLDER PARTNERS ARE FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WORK AND HELPING US
UNDERSTAND. THE SYSTEM AND WHAT
THEIR NEEDS WERE IN THE SYSTEM
AT. THE CURRENT USE. SYSTEM IS
THAT RIGHT THAT WAS OUR REALLY
HELP FOR ME TO UNDER. KIND OF
THE COMPLEXITY OF THE PROBLEM.
WOULD YOU SAY WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT OUR
CAPACITY IS RIGHT NOW. NO I
WOULDN'T SAY THAT I DO THINK WE
ACTUALLY HAVE- A FAIRLY GOOD MIX
OF DISABILITIES THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO STAND UP I WOULDN'T SAY-
CONFIDENT SAYING THAT EVERY.
BECAUSE THE MIX OF EVERY
FACILITY THEY NEED. BUT I AM
CONFIDENT THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
TOOLS IN OUR TOOL BELT WITH IN
OUR CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL
LICENSE CAPACITY TO HELP PEOPLE
MEET THE NEEDS AND FIND THE
RIGHT SOLUTION SO THAT CHILDREN
ARE BEING SERVED IN THE MOST
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT. THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT- AND- WITH
THAT. SEEING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES I THINK WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND- GO TO THE PUBLIC FOR
THEIR COMMENT. AND WE WILL START
RIGHT HERE WE HAVE A LOT BEFORE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. FOR
THOSE WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME
FORWARD. STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION OF ANY AND BRIEF
COMMENTS WELCOME. THANK YOU
VENTURE MEMBERS BEVERLY YOU ON
BEHALF OF UWF'S ME LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY THANK YOU FOR THE
HEARING TODAY WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF MISS RAMSEY'S
CONFIRMATION ASK THE CHIEF
DEPUTY RECTOR DISABILITY TO
HOUSING INTEGRATION POSITION WE
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH MISS RAMSEY HER PREVIOUS
ROLES. AND SHE HAS DEMONSTRATED
OUTSTANDING TRACK RECORD OF
DEDICATED SERVICE AND COMPASSION
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF OLDER ADULTS CHILDREN
AND IMPROVING THE CRITICAL
SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAMS. WE
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE AROUND CHILDCARE
AND HSS TODAY AND HER RESPONSES
WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT HER
CONFIRMATIONS A LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK WITH HER
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SEEING NO FOR- MEMBERS OF THE-
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND GO BACK TO OUR
MODERATOR FOR THE
TELECONFERENCE- OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO WEAR AGAIN. AND AGAIN
THAT TOLL FREE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE THE ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO.
AND WITH THAT- MISTER MODERATOR
WELCOME BACK. OKAY IF YOU'D LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO. AND
THIS IS FOR PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ONE
IN CUBA COMES ONLINE THREE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY
WHITE WITH S. B. R. U.
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING CHILD
CARE WORKERS COUNTY WORKERS IN
HOME CARE WORKERS PROUD IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
THE TRANSPORTATION- AGAIN WE'VE
WORKED WITH HER. A PHONE INTO
CAPACITY- SHE IS KNOWLEDGEABLE
OF THE ISSUES AND HAVE HAD THE
WILLINGNESS TO WALK THROUGH A
MEMBER ANY CHALLENGES OKAY AND
IT. BUT I. THE AND BUDGET AFTER
IS WHAT OF THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MUCH R. O. WITNESSES
QUEUED AT THE POINT MATER. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE THE- COMES FROM
THE LINE OF THREE OH WITH. THIS
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE GAME CLOCK ON. IN
A CALLING AND WE- USE ME WE I'M
SORRY WE YOU CUT OUT FOR A
SECOND WOULD YOU AGAIN STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD AND
THEN CONTINUE THANK YOU. YES
YEAH I MEAN ARE AFTER WE COME ON
BOARD UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
GETTING A BAD CONNECTION- HAVE
YOU MUTED THE DEVICE YOU'RE
LISTENING TO THE HEARING ON I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET YOUR
TESTIMONY BUT YOU'RE BREAKING UP
TO THE POINT THAT OUR COURT
REPORTER CAN OP WE WILL. EARLY
YES LET ME TRY ONE MORE TIME- GO
AHEAD HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU WEDNESDAY JAN CLOT ON BEHALF
OF DEFICITS AGING CALLING IN
STRONG OR IF THEIR BRAND IS
CONFIRMATION. WHERE THEY WORK
THE BEST THING AGING FOR SIX
YEARS AND HER WORK HERE
CONTINUES TO BEING TODAY HE
LEADS THE EXPANSION OF
PROTECTION AS AND IF THE COURT
THE NEEDS AND EXPERIENCES OF LOW
INCOME OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION TO YOUR ADMIRABLE
EXPERTISE- ON HFS AND HER
UNDERSTANDING- ENDED UP GETTING
COMPLEX POLICY SHOULD ADDRESS A
COMMITMENT TAXI PRIORITIZE
ALICIA AND WE DON'T PARTNERSHIP
ACROSS THE COMMUNITY AND STATE
RECORDS TO AND TOPPLED THAT WE
SEE TODAY AND CONTINUE TO COME
TO. EVERYTHING IN LIFE I THE. IT
FOR POPULAR COULD FACE A COURT
FAMILY AND YOU'VE BEEN MAN AND
IT'S REALLY A- CALL TO WORK WITH
ALL THE- AND MUCH MORE FROM THE
COURT. CLARION YOU THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
FOR YOUR- MISTER MODERATOR OTHER
SPEAKERS. WE HAVE NO FOR IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE PRE SOME
YOUR HELP- WE WILL NOW TURN TO
MEMBERS WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION I
DON'T SEE ANYONE APPROACH IN THE
DYESS IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SO MISTER
MODERATOR I WILL COME BACK TO
YOU TO TEE UP ANYONE THAT MIGHT
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PROPOSITION. ONE ZERO.
ALLOWING A FEW MOMENTS WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP TODAY. I
LET ME- COME BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE AND WE'VE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEMBERS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO REMOVE IT. I WILL I
WILL I HAD MANY PEOPLE MOVE ON
THE MOTION BUT ALL LETTER VICE
CHAIR SENATOR BATES GET THAT
HONOR- AND SO MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROF I
GROW BY KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER II
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES AYE
BATES AYE ATKINS HIGH ATKINS ON
A FIVE TWO ZERO THAT IS FIVE TWO
ZERO I CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
CONGRADULATIONS WE WILL MOVE
THIS APPOINTMENT ONTO THE SENATE
FLOOR FOR FULL CONFIRMATION AND
WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ALL ALL THE BEST THANK YOU. OKAY
THAT. INCLUDES OUR- THE PUBLIC
PORTION OF OUR AGENDA TODAY I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO DID PARTICIPATE
IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF YOU
WEREN'T ABLE TO TESTIFY ABOUT
YOU WISH TO YOU CAN STILL SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO OUR RULES COMMITTEE
R. OR VISIT THE WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT AND WE
WANT TO INCREASE YOUR- IT FISHEL
BIRTH AND SO WITH THAT LET ME
AGAIN THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION ARE
COMMITTEE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
RULES WILL NOW MOVE TO EXECUTIVE
SESSION.